[Música]
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 si revelan con
gusto saludarlos y bienvenidos a este
especial de noticias donde a partir de
ese momento y por las próximas dos horas
y media vamos a llevarles todo el
cubrimiento del cuarto y último día de
la convención nacional demócrata en eeuu
para ello les transmitiremos los
discursos seguiremos en unos minutos con
nuestras corresponsales en la ciudad de
nueva york y en washington dice además
por supuesto de nuestros invitados
analistas recordemos que este año debido
a la pandemia de coronavirus la
convención del partido se realiza de
manera virtual por primera vez en la
historia el día de hoy se esperan los
discursos de cory booker senador o por
el por new years eve beat bourget ex
candidato presidencial y ex alcalde es
out bend indiana michael bloomberg
empresario y ex alcalde de la ciudad de
nueva york entre otros y por supuesto el
plato fuerte de la noche el discurso del
candidato demócrata a la presidencia de
eeuu joe biden
este discurso de biden es una plataforma
importante para los demócratas pues
debido a la crisis de este coronavirus
los actos de campaña han quedado
reducidos y el presidente de donald
trump ha tenido más oportunidad de
dirigirse a las personas y es que
precisamente hoy para boicotear este
discurso son se dirigió a pensilvania el
estado natal de bailén para un acto
público se espera en este último día de
convención que bardem entregue su plan
de gobierno en el que la política
migratoria será uno de sus caballos de
batalla del exvicepresidente y ha
prometido además que de llegar a la casa
blanca se encargará de deshacer el daño
causado por esta administración así lo
dijo joe biden además hay expectativa
por su plan económico todo esto ocurre
también cuando steve banon ex estratega
de donald trump fue detenido por un
presunto millonario fraude en la
recaudación de fondos para la
construcción del muro en la frontera con
méxico el considerado artífice de la
victoria electoral del tram de 2016 fue
arrestado en un yate y se declaró
culpable
bien ya he dicho esto todo lo que está
ocurriendo en este momento dentro de la
política estadounidense dentro del
dentro del territorio estadounidense
quiero ir a la ciudad de nueva york con
una de nuestras corresponsables que nos
va a acompañar a mensah la mamen que
tengo usted una muy buena noche le
quiero preguntar entonces que vamos a
esperar esta noche el último día de la
convención demócrata y a lo mejor
recordar un poco de como visto durante
todos estos últimos tres días
muy buenas noches las de nueva york pues
hoy lo que vamos a ver es la culminación
de esos cuatro días de esta típica
inusual y virtual convención demócrata y
desde luego el momento más importante va
a ser cuando joe biden acepte esa
nominación probablemente desde delaware
para enfrentarse al 3 de noviembre al
presidente
donald trump dicen desde su campaña que
está más que preparado para este momento
que lleva más de 30 años preparándose
para ello debemos recordar que yo vaivén
ya ha tenido tres intentos de llegar a
la casa blanca a los dos anteriores
fueron en el 1998 y en el 2008 entonces
pues bueno parece que esta vez pues
podría estar más cerca o no lo veremos
durante esta noche lo que yo va a ir en
va a intentar en su discurso desde
delaware en un espacio de eventos en el
que va a estar completamente vacío
prácticamente vacío por esta situación
que estamos viviendo es convencer a los
ciudadanos estadounidenses de que por
supuesto es la mejor opción contarles un
poquito cuál va a ser
de ruta para estos cuatro años y va a
intentar mostrar a través de su historia
personal como él puede ser capaz de
conectar de conseguir esa unión entre
los estadounidenses y acabar dice con la
crisis y el caos que hay ahora mismo en
eeuu como decías tiene armas nuevas hoy
para enfrentarse verbalmente al
presidente o atacarle si quiere con esta
nueva situación que hemos vivido con la
detención de steve steve balón va a ser
muy interesante también porque veremos
un vídeo hecho con amigos conocidos que
nos hablarán una vez más de joe biden
con sus nietos también con sus hijos y
otra fórmula también muy interesante que
es cómo se ven determinados ciudadanos o
incluso líderes del partido dentro de un
año por estas fechas cuando bailen
supuestamente sea el presidente como
decías también contaremos con la
intervención por remoto de manera remota
de antiguos contrincantes en estas
primarias como son el alcalde de south
bend pitbull tickets al senador por
nueva yersey
corey brock
y luego bueno escucharemos también al ex
alcalde de la ciudad de nueva york
michael bloomberg quien fue muy crítico
con joe biden pero no debemos olvidar
que ha anunciado que aportará 60
millones de dólares a la campaña
demócrata así que de alguna manera se ha
ganado su posición esta noche durante
estos días hemos visto raúl pues las
principales figuras del partido
demócrata ha sido muy interesante esa
mezcla entre viejas glorias del partido
con esas nuevas figuras más jóvenes que
quieren dar también un nuevo sentido a
este partido un nuevo una nueva cara
para atraer a digamos a los votantes
jóvenes para atraer a las mujeres lo
hemos dicho lo hemos visto a través de
la vicepresidenta por ejemplo kamala
harris cómo va a atraer la posible a
vicepresidenta cómo va a atraer a
mujeres afroamericanas mujeres latinas
lo hemos visto también a través de la
legisladora alexandra ocasio cortes
entonces pues bueno esto va a ser una
noche de culminación de todo lo que
hemos visto estos cuatro días en el que
hemos escuchado
voces políticas como voces de ciudadanos
que confían en sí la interrumpe este
momento porque está hablando entonces
uno de los oradores de esta noche y
escuchemos
se preguntan si los verdes estarán a la
altura de los retos pero debemos darle a
este país la oportunidad de recuperarse
y la recuperación solamente es posible a
través del cambio de un liderazgo con
nuevas ideas con políticas audaces que
pondrán las cosas en sus manos en medio
de estas crisis y eso es posible no
necesitamos ayuda para capotear la
página en 75 días estamos aquí para
celebrar a joe biden y su nominación
como el candidato demócrata para la
presidencia
yo conozco el show y la cámara ellos
conocí en la campaña y la manera como
los conoces cuando ya no están las
cámaras y la gente se ha ido es
simplemente tú y ellos son personas
reales que comprenden los problemas que
enfrentamos son padres y patriotas que
quieren lo mejor para nosotros y el país
y si les damos la oportunidad van a
luchar
nosotros y nuestras familias cada día
nuestro futuro es ahora y es muy pesado
pero les pido que se unan en mí para
luchar por la promesa de eeuu para que
ellos nos puedan liberar hacia un futuro
del cual estemos orgullosos de dejarle a
nuestros hijos ahora la palabra a una
gran demócrata que todos tenemos como
semis
qué pensaste del discurso de cámara de
anoche fue tremendo
también fue fabulosa no puedo esperar a
verla debatir con el señor mike pence
mica pains cómo es que es un nombre que
dice la gente bueno muchas gracias a
dios por favor saludarlos a todos estos
viejitos en el cuarto de al lado gracias
georgia buenas tardes y eeuu y
bienvenidos al acuerdo ya empezamos
entonces a entrar en materia de lo que
va a hacer este último y cuarto día de
la convención demócrata en estados
unidos estaban viendo anteriormente a
andy xiang ex candidato presidencial y
también empresario estadounidense y
antes de eso estábamos hablando con
nuestra corresponsal en nueva york que
mamá en sala y pues también quiero
recordar a nuestros invitados
a los televidentes que a medida de que
se vayan dando estos discursos de los
oradores de la noche vamos a estar
interrumpiendo en
opiniones para ir con los discursos y
también pues analizar sobre lo que dicen
los oradores y ahora sí luego la palabra
nuevamente a mamen mamen vuelvo contigo
si raúl básicamente lo que estaba estaba
terminando de comentar que lo que hemos
visto lo que veremos esta noche es un
poco la culminación de todo lo que hemos
visto en estas cuatro jornadas que han
sido básicamente dedicadas a que todo el
entorno del candidato joe biden ponga
este candidato demócrata en valor y
explique las virtudes de que puede tener
que yo gaiden salga elegido presidente
el 3 de noviembre pues ahora es su turno
a explicarle a los ciudadanos
estadounidenses por qué tienen que votar
le y qué es lo que puede hacer por ellos
en los próximos cuatro años ha sido
desde luego cuatro jornadas muy ágiles
en las que la parte tecnológica que
preocupaba bastante al partido ha
funcionado bastante bien en la que a
pesar de que no ha habido confetis
globos y aplausos reales los vídeos y
aplausos virtuales han podido hacer que
poco a poco esté estas cuatro jornadas
fueran bastante ágiles así que hoy sólo
queda esperar a ver cuál es este
discurso que cerrará la noche de esta
cuarta jornada de una típica y virtual
convención demócrata
así es mamá ahora voy con nuestra
corresponsal en la capital
estadounidense washington 16 diana
castañeda diana la saludo buena noche y
le quiero preguntar entonces lo que
ocurre en ese momento en la política
estadounidense que ha pasado con esta
contra campaña que está haciendo el
presidente de donald trump justo cuando
se espera que esta noche ya acepte la
bueno ya le aceptó la nominación pero él
cede el discurso entonces del candidato
presidencial
joe biden por los demócratas
bueno pues estamos viendo esta
culminación de la convención demócrata
en medio de una coyuntura de varios
aspectos relacionados con la campaña
primero el presidente de donald trump ha
tratado de hacer digamos una publicidad
en contra de la votación de correo
asegurando que no es una forma segura de
hacerlo esto ha levantado las voces por
ejemplo de la fiscal general james de
nueva york que asegurando que si el
presidente intenta tratar de demorar las
elecciones o incluso tratar de evitar
que los estadounidenses ejerzan ese
derecho a votar entonces la fiscal
actuarán y en medio de esta campaña
también las noticias de hoy muestran
como uno de los hombres más cercanos al
presidente de donald trump van jones es
arrestado por presuntamente haber
cometido el fraude al obtener dinero de
contribuyentes de los eeuu para
financiar el muro en la frontera con
mexico y tener cerca de un millón de
dólares en sus cuentas personales
de este dinero pero también el que el
presidente de donald trump quiera tener
la atención esta noche justo cuando se
espera el gran discurso de baile en
todos estos son elementos que digamos
empiezan a calentar los motores de lo
que pueden ser estos dos últimos meses
dos meses y medio para llegar a las
elecciones de noviembre 3 y por eso es
que justo el día de hoy se espera esta
noche que yo bailen de su discurso más
importante ayer vimos a kamala harris
haciendo un discurso muy centrado en la
justicia racial y el de hoy se espera un
discurso muy centrado en la economía
pero en la economía no solo en un plan
para crear más empleos en los eeuu o
incrementar el salario mínimo a 15
dólares en la hora sino un plan de
recuperación de recuperación debido a la
crisis financiera que está enfrentando
los eeuu donde hay 40 millones de
personas que están tratando de conseguir
trabajos que han solicitado subsidios al
desempleo
donde las minorías más afectadas han
sido los afroamericanos y los latinos
por eso también hablara yo bayrén en
referencia a tener acceso a cuidado en
salud y brindar mayor acceso a las
minorías que son las que se han visto
más afectadas y cuyo plan de generar más
acceso a la salud durante esta
administración se ha visto afectado
después de que el presidente de donald
trump llevará varias veces al congreso
esta iniciativa para acabar obamacare
por supuesto también veremos un discurso
con dos temas importantes para joe biden
y la campaña de los demócratas la
reforma migratoria para cerca de 12
millones de inmigrantes indocumentados
protecciones para jóvenes indocumentados
que tienen daca y tienen tps otros y se
espera que hable de su plan de cambio
climático algo que ha sido digamos lo
opuesto por parte de los republicanos
durante la administración del presidente
de donald trump así que esto es lo que
veremos esta noche en esta
aceptación oficial que se espera por
parte de joe biden y después de esto ya
veremos algo similar a lo que vimos esta
semana pero el turno será para los
republicanos la próxima semana así es
diana que también por supuesto vamos a
estar cubriendo los días de convención
como lo hemos hecho hasta hoy el último
y cuarto día de la convención demócrata
ya para entrar en debate entonces quiero
empezar a presentar a mis invitados de
la noche de hoy empiezo con ron al de
aledo analista político y de seguridad
además estratega republicano nos atiende
desde la ciudad de miami en el estado de
la florida y también robert valència
analista político internacional y nos
entiende muy amablemente desde la ciudad
de nueva york que también en eeuu
saludos al señor aledo y también al
señor valència por atendernos en este
momento vamos a entrar entonces en
materia económica como lo decía nuestra
corresponsal en washington diana
castañeda una
un plan de recuperación económica que se
espera que presente en el candidato
demócrata a la presidencia
joe biden que puede hacer vaivén para
recuperar la economía del país tras este
desplome en la economía por cuenta de la
pandemia de kobe de 19 preguntas usted
ron al dedo
escucha sí creo que creo que hay un
problema de comunicación con el señor
aledo en la ciudad de miami voy con
usted entonces robert haciendo un poco
en la pregunta que con la que comenzaba
con el señor aledo y era que que puedes
que puede hacer entonces el candidato by
the end para el luchar con este desplome
de la economía estadounidense por cuenta
de la pandemia de kobe 19 cuál sería el
plan que va a presentar el candidato
bueno primero que todo muchísimas
gracias normalmente por estar aquí en su
programa es un placer estar contigo raúl
y obviamente un placer estar con todos
los televidentes bueno yo creo que lo
principal es organizar el tema del
coronavirus y cómo manejar la pandemia
yo creo que si lo que hemos visto en
estos últimos meses es una falta de
balance y obviamente sabemos que no es
fácil procurar abrir la economía en
medio de una pandemia porque por
supuesto los estadounidenses requieren
trabajos y requieren un salario un
ingreso sostenible pero en medio de una
pandemia pues se hace imposible reabrir
la economía en su totalidad y esto lo
hemos visto en estados como texas como
georgia incluso a la florida en donde
los donde sus gobernantes procuraron
abrir las economías demasiado pronto y
lo que vimos fue un repunte y un rebrote
del coronavirus y volvemos nuevamente a
cerrar los negocios es difícil encontrar
ese equilibrio por supuesto yo creo que
tiene que haber un tipo de economía
escalonada como lo ha venido haciendo
por ejemplo el estado de nueva york en
donde los negocios han ido abriéndose
por fases y yo
porque eso va a tender va a tener que
implementarse tal vez desde un punto
federal y yo creo que ahí es donde entra
en juego la administración sea quien sea
sea la de trump o sea la de bailén y el
de procurar activar reactivar la
economía por sectores y no quiere
abrirlo todo
al unísono que es prácticamente lo que
hemos visto en estos últimos meses y
obviamente pues garantizarle a las
comunidades más desfavorecidas entre
ellas los hispanos que como lo acaba de
decir la corresponsal en washington los
hispanos son los que han se han visto
mayormente afectados cito números del
centro pew es un centro prestigioso aquí
en eeuu que señala que los niveles de
desempleo de entre los hispanos han sido
los peores desde que entramos nosotros
en la gran recesión del 2008 y del 2009
en donde la tasa de desempleo circunda
los el 13,9 por ciento el perdón me
equivoco es 20 5% entre febrero y abril
de este año incluso ya los hispanos
estaban viendo un un descenso en el
empleo en sus niveles de empleo antes de
que llegara la pandemia que como ustedes
saben pues entró con mucha fuerza en
eeuu alrededor del mes de marzo y es
asegurarles no solamente un empleo por
asegurarles un empleo yo creo que hay
que asegurar un empleo de calidad porque
siempre nos basamos en los números que
saca el gobierno cada mes y decir bueno
hemos aumentado en los números de
trabajos o de trabajos disponibles pero
en realidad es hay que señalar qué tipos
de trabajo son estos son trabajos que
garantizan un seguro de un seguro de
vida que les permitan a ellos subsistir
digamos horas de trabajo
normales como la de 955 y sus trabajos
sean remunerados tienen que trabajar más
allá de las 8 horas de ausencia por
paternidad por maternidad etcétera yo
creo que eso también vale la pena
rescatarlo porque no solamente estamos
hablando de los números sino de la
calidad de los trabajos yo no soy
economista esos son básicamente mis
puntos de vista obviamente pues igual yo
creo que así como ocurrió en el 2008 he
llegado al caso que llegue que llegado
el caso que gane el vaivén pues va a
tener un trabajo bastante difícil porque
son 30 millones de desempleados es una
cifra récord lamentablemente y
probablemente como lo han dicho algunos
expertos esos trabajos tal vez no
vuelvan más robert y ya se están viendo
entonces esas reclamaciones sociales por
parte de esos empleados que como ustedes
lo dijo a lo mejor exigen un trabajo de
calidad le hemos visto con las
manifestaciones de los empleados en
restaurantes por ejemplo de comidas de
comidas rápidas en todo eeuu que
reclaman la seguridad que reclaman
pensión que reclaman salud y entonces
por ese tema también me quiero ir ahora
le quiero dar la palabra al señor aledo
que nos atiende desde la ciudad de miami
en el estado de la florida no sé si ya
pude escuchar lo que estaba diciendo
nuestro invitado desde la ciudad de
nueva york es señor valència y le quiero
preguntar entonces cómo encontrar el
equilibrio del que él también hablaba
entre la apertura económica pero también
de preservar la vida porque estamos
atravesando por esta pandemia de kobe 19
que además en eeuu ya más de 170 mil
personas han perdido la vida por la
enfermedad
hola muy buenas espero que me puedan
escuchar a ver sí sí exactamente muy
bien pues gracias por la habitación yo
creo que el baile no es lo que va a
hacer es hablar ya había hablado
anteriormente de su mensaje creo que
estaba había copiado de hecho a los
varios puntos de donald trump comprar
cosas americanas productos americanos
por hechos aquí y creo que va a intentar
hablar de una forma muy técnica sobre la
economía para intentar darle una
apariencia muy moderada tecnócrata muy
de números muy de matemáticas a la
conferencia
toda esta convención demócrata para que
para presentársela a sí mismo como una
persona moderada de centro para tratar
de llamar la atención de enviar la
atención del ala más izquierdista que el
que ha salido en las últimas semanas y
meses en la televisión entonces él va a
hablar de economía y de temas muy
técnicos ya empezó hace unas semanas a
hablar para comprar productos americanos
va a seguir en esa línea
creo que la economía va a mejorar
porque hay que ver que muchas cosas
la relación entre el pandemia y economía
son cosas completamente que se oponen en
sí mismo una cosa es cerrar la economía
obviamente se destruye la economía se
limita la pandemia pero hay que mantener
ese balance fino entre qué punto hay que
mantener la salud y hasta qué punto vale
la pena destruir la economía cerrar los
negocios los bares los restaurantes
dejar a la gente sin trabajo dejar a la
gente sin comida hay que ver que por
ejemplo en agosto 5 se publicó un
estudio
del journal of public health que es muy
revelador de cómo la los casos de la
pandemia subieron enormemente a causa de
las protestas por la muerte de georg
floyd en atlanta subieron hasta 6% en
houston 19 puntos 64% en jacksonville
florida subieron 34 punto 24 en miami 9%
en orlando 53 por ciento etcétera o sea
que el journal of public health
demuestra una relación muy profunda
entre miles de personas gritando sin
mascarilla uno al lado del otro
protestando riot in to get there y el
aumento de la pandemia ahora es
diferente al tema ahora el tema es cómo
abrir la economía a un nivel normal y
dejar que la gente pueda comer que la
gente hispana y los negros y los blancos
y todo lo que tiene un restaurante que
han sido cerrados barbería que han sido
cerrados bares que han sido cerrados
tiendas que han sido cerradas puedan
volver a ganar el sustento de la vida y
quiero que este baile ahora se va a
mantener muy técnico muy tecnócrata no
quiere que la atención vaya alejandro
cancio cortes
grandío ni al aborto de later ni a los
transcender ni nada de eso quiere que
presentarse como el candidato de centro
moderado y hablar de números economía
gracias en aledo por su opinión quiero
saludar también a nuestra próxima
invitada maría fernanda vos mosky ella
es directora asociada del centro
adrienne arsht para américa latina del
atlántico con sus gracias al señor a vos
mosky por aceptar nuestra invitación
para este especial de noticias como bien
lo estaba escuchando estábamos hablando
con nuestros dos invitados sobre la
economía del país pero el señor aledo
también esto con un tema muy importante
y es sobre el discurso que iba a
pronunciar que se espera que pronuncie
esta noche candidato demócrata joe va
bien hablaba que se va a mostrar como un
candidato muy de centro pero entonces
cómo hacer para captar esos votos desde
el ala más progresista
de lara más izquierdista del partido
demócrata estadounidense como alexandra
ocasio cortes también que pronunció su
discurso y que dijo que su apoyo era
para progresando es como ser para para
captar esos votos y que a lo mejor no se
pierdan o se vayan para
para el bando republicano
ahora sí muchas gracias por la
invitación y los saludos desde milwaukee
de hecho donde se suponía que iba a
tomar lugar está esta serie esta
convención y estas series de discursos
que hemos visto los días anteriores y
veremos hoy con cuando el candidato yo
bailén acepte la nominación de su
partido
el tema yo creo que hemos visto que el
partido demócrata no es un partido
monolítico que tiene varios matices
y sin duda alguna será será una ardua de
este labor desde aquí desde ahora hasta
el 3 de noviembre para que para el que
el partido demócrata logre capturar esos
votos progresistas que que en algún
momento se hubieran ido al candidato
bernie sanders el tema de la nominación
que le dio la representante de la
congresista alexander ocasión cortés
al senador sanders es un tema meramente
protocolario se puede hacer y no
significa que no estén apoyando o que no
estén esté detrás del candidato yo bailé
inclusive bernie sanders en abril cuando
dejó cuando salió de la campaña dijo que
iba a respaldar al candidato en bailén y
bueno son sólo temas protocolarios de
nuevo no quiere decir que ella no vaya a
respaldar a job island ella tendrá un
papel importante para yo bailé en
capturar esos votos progresistas que en
muchas ocasiones el votante de ese ala
más progresista se asemeja mucho con el
votante de la base del que le es leal al
presidente de donald trump y hay muchas
similitudes como lo son el
proteccionismo
un poco el nacionalismo también y bueno
será como decía yo al principio una
ardua tarea desde ahora hasta el 3 de
noviembre para que el partido se una
detrás del candidato yo byron y logre
capturar esos votos que pudieran irse
hacia hacia los republicanos bueno santo
donald trump gracias maria fernanda
quiero ir entonces ahora y me quiero
quedar con lo que usted estaba diciendo
que hay falta mucho de aquí al 3 de
noviembre hay una tarea por hacer y
quiero precisamente preguntarle al señor
valència en la ciudad de nueva york que
podemos esperar de ahora en adelante en
esta campaña demócrata para finalmente
que lograr su objetivo que es
evidentemente ganarle al presidente de
unalt son buenas urnas el 3 de noviembre
que podemos ver en la campaña demócrata
yo creo que de aquí en adelante los
demócratas tienen que ya entrar en
profundidad sobre los planes que tienen
para las personas o los grupos votantes
que tal vez en esta en esta convención
se hayan sentido aislados me refiero
particularmente en el caso de los
hispanos regularmente estas convenciones
sirven para introducir para presentar
sangre nueva si se quiere decir de esa
manera dentro del partido demócrata como
lo como lo que ocurrió en el 2004 cuando
vimos la figura emergente en barack
obama quien dio un discurso que fue
aplaudido por muchos y que obviamente
fue el el sendero que se abrió adelante
para lanzarse a la presidencia y pues
como ya sabemos ya el resto es historia
lamentablemente lo que no hemos visto
aquí en esta convención es la sangre
nueva
para proyectar futuros líderes
demócratas me parece que en este caso
los demócratas tuvieron una visión
bastante cortoplacista prefirieron darle
espacios a los a las personas de la
vieja guardia de los demócratas y eso
también yo creo que es una de las
observaciones que hay que ver no está
julián castro quien es una figura
importante demócrata y que es hispano es
tal vez uno de las figuras hispanas más
sobresalientes por supuesto también
salió hilda solís salió mi sangre de
luján que es la gobernadora de nuevo
méxico salió alexandria ocasión corte
pero ellas no tuvieron un lugar
preponderante en estas conversaciones
digamos sus intervenciones formaron
prácticamente hay un minuto y tal vez es
esos discursos quien en el olvido de
hecho lo único que sobresalió de la
charla o de la conversación que dio
alexandra clásico
fue la confusión a la cual se refiere la
invitada en milwaukee que era que se le
había dado el respaldo al bernie sanders
y quitado el respaldo a job haití
se forjó una una confusión cuando como
ella misma lo menciona era un tema
protocolario y yo creo que de aquí en
adelante los demócratas y bueno yo
también esperaría que los republicanos
expresaran su interés su verdadero
interés por la comunidad hispana porque
como vuelvo y enfatizó es la comunidad
más golpeada y si hay algo que esté
coronavirus ha revelado son las enormes
y desproporcionadas diferencias entre
hispanos y el resto de la comunidad en
esta de las comunidades aquí en eeuu
fueron principalmente los trabajadores
esenciales desde enfermeros hasta
conductores de buses hasta trabajadores
empacadores en supermercados y muchos de
ellos fallecieron
hay que ver que muchas de esas personas
que trabajaban en esos trabajos
esenciales valga la redundancia no
tenían
y un puro médico asequible y no
lamentablemente tenían grabados donde no
se les permitía estar en un lugar de
hacinamiento tenían que estar en la
primera fila de este virus que por lo
menos aquí en la ciudad de nueva york
tuvo efectos completamente devastadores
si el partido demócrata realmente quiere
conquistar el voto hispano pues va a
tener que hacer un muy un mayor énfasis
en los temas que le importan a los
hispanos desde el tema migratorio hasta
el tema de la economía pasando por el
cambio climático que también es uno de
los temas bastante importantes para los
hispanos y donde obviamente los
republicanos pues tienen un récord pobre
en estos tres años y medio donde una
cantidad de desregulación es que han
perjudicado y exacerbado de hecho las
condiciones
y el enlace el vínculo que hay entre
industrias contaminantes que se han
beneficiado con la administración de
donald trump y los efectos de las
comorbilidades que sufrieron los
hispanos que los que a muchos de ellos
los llevaron a la muerte por korda virus
así que yo creo que esos son los temas
que va a tener que abordar de una manera
concisa con profundidad y darle el lugar
que merecen los hispanos de aquí en
adelante porque estamos que pronosticado
que los hispanos seremos la mayoría en
este país de aquí a unos 30
robert usted hablaba de la falta de esa
sangre nueva dentro del partido
demócrata estadounidense y le quiero
preguntar al señor aledo en la ciudad de
miami falta liderazgo dentro del partido
demócrata un liderazgo a lo mejor como
el que tuvo el ex presidente barack
obama porque además el mismo joe biden
dijo que iba a ser un candidato de
transición y por eso también eligió a
cámara carles una mujer de 55 años de
edad relativamente relativamente joven
para asumir un nuevo mandato en caso de
de postularse a las elecciones dentro
cuatro años más tarde es de ganar de
ganar las elecciones el partido
demócrata este año contra el presidente
donald trump
bueno en mi opinión yo lo que lo que
creo es que el entusiasmo
no está con los seguidores de baile no
está con los seguidores de él ni está
con la plataforma que representa bailen
como bien menciona este es lo que pasó
con obama en el 2008 fue un fenómeno
social cultural
solamente había que ver los dibujos que
hacían las pancartas de arte que hacían
con la cara de obama y el yes we can no
se puede había millones y millones de
personas con mucha esperanza muy
excitados por el primer persona negro o
mulata de padre negro africano que va a
ser presidente de eeuu y eso creó una
avalancha de emociones y de una
avalancha de emocional y de pasión
detrás de la cantidad de la candidatura
de obama y ahora me parece a mí que eso
no no
es algo que tenga baile ni mucho menos
al contrario va a ir desde la misma
persona que ya intentó anteriormente es
el presidente y fallo y la pasión o la
energía estaba con la juventud
especialmente chicos universitarios que
son los que estaban detrás de bernie
sanders y detrás de alejandro casi
aportes
a la izquierdista más progresista
izquierdista del partido y me parece a
mí que de la campaña de biden ven que no
tienen esa esa pasión que no tiene esa
emoción detrás y están tratando de jugar
6 de jugar seguro de presentarlo como el
candidato de centro de traer a viejas
caras a que den mensajes cortos y no
quieren que se desvíe la atención
quieren poner experiencia de vaivén que
lleva a cuarenta y tantos de año como
senador por delaware quieren poner sus
canas su experiencia como vicepresidente
-hay la edad y quieren minimizar las
caras nuevas o jóvenes o personas que
vayan posiblemente a sustituir a bailes
en el futuro lo que vaya a tratar de ser
candidatos de aquí a cuatro años y
quiero que me parece a mí que es una
estrategia para jugar seguro porque
saben que no tienen la pasión ni kamala
harris tampoco cama las heridas mucha
gente de la comunidad afroamericana
tampoco tiene emoción por ella al
contrario la ven como una figura
distante como una que era prosecutor que
era
que puso a la gente que fuma marihuana
en la cárcel como una mujer que cuando
llegó al senado no dijo que era soy la
primera negra aquí y yo soy negra que
llega al senado soy india americana de
la india por poniendo sus ancestros de
la india por encima de sus ancestros
negros jamaiquino yo creo que es una es
un ticket que no tiene la emoción no
tiene la pasión y me parece que debe de
estar jugando seguro para ocultar caras
nuevas y poner más bien su experiencia y
sus muchos años en washington en el
centro de su discurso
maría fernanda quiero ir con usted hasta
milwaukee en wisconsin preguntarle
entonces que le falta a esa fórmula
harris by den para lograr esa pasión del
voto a lo mejor latino o de los votantes
para que voten con energía y como
también decían los discursos de los
oradores que voten como si la vida
dependiera de eso sí lo dijo michele
obama si lo dijo hillary clinton que
falta
si primero este quiero decir que esta
esta convención es sin precedentes el
mundo está viviendo un momento sin
precedentes
todo eso lo sabemos
sin embargo la nominación de bardem como
candidato yo creo que eso no tiene no es
sin precedentes
lo hemos visto muy común que sea un
hombre blanco y con años ya sea con
carrera política y con recursos que sea
el candidato presidencial en ese sentido
no es nada nuevo y yo creo que por eso
puede ser que no exista ese entusiasmo
que existía que tal vez con bueno con
alexander cortes en un casino se ha
postulado pero pero con su figura y con
esa sangre nueva
pero si para los demócratas es la vida
depende de lo que pase en noviembre y
hasta cierto punto creo que en el 2015
cuando donald trump lanzó su candidatura
muchos se rieron
y no pensaban que fuera primero a ganar
la nominación del partido republicano y
después no pensaron que le iba a ganar a
hillary clinton una mujer con años de
experiencia y aseguren ahora perdón este
este secretaria de estado una mujer con
mucha experiencia en el partido
republicano
perdona el partido demócrata no no no
está generando esa emoción pero también
creo que vale la pena resaltar que hemos
visto de manera de nuevo sin precedentes
una rechazo
al presidente de donald trump y al
candidato republicano por parte de
personas que son que han sido
tradicionalmente parte del establishment
republicano este hace hace poco vimos
esa carta que más de 70 republicanos
asesores de seguridad y gente de
administraciones republicanas pasadas
este salieron diciendo que van a votar
por joe biden yo bailé puede que no sea
el orador más activo o más
en gaming este que más llame la atención
pero este sí el él es muy reconocido por
su tendencia de crear puentes este su
carrera en el senado fue este tuvo
muchas victorias bipartidistas y yo creo
que si lo están jugando seguro pero yo
creo que a estas alturas para el partido
este demócrata es es muy importante
retomar la presidencia
veremos qué pasa con el senado creo que
seguramente la casa del representante
siga con mayoría demócrata pero pero
para los demócratas es precisa están
jugando el futuro de su país
hablemos ahora de otro tema importante
de la noche y es el de las minorías a lo
mejor también en la comunidad lgtb
porque se espera el discurso de
pittsburgh ets y también de la comunidad
afroamericana la comunidad hispana y
quiero volver con robert valencia porque
él estaba diciendo un punto muy
importante con respecto a estas minorías
del decía que los hispanos y la forma y
los afroamericanos son los que más han
sufrido por esta pandemia tanto en el
número de infectados por coronavirus
también como el número de desempleados
las comunidades más desamparadas y le
pregunto porque robert
por lo que acabo de mencionar yo creo
que lamentablemente estamos viendo ha
habido una una desigualdad en eeuu
histórica yo creo que eso nos podríamos
extender y podremos hacer una
conferencia magistral respecto al tema
pero lo ha habido desde hace mucho
tiempo pensando con los afroamericanos
lamentablemente que todavía siguen
sufriendo los embates de un racismo
institucional y eso todavía se ha visto
reflejado en el hecho de que vivan en
comunidades donde están donde corren el
mayor riesgo de contraer el coronavirus
1 porque son en gran parte también son
trabajadores esenciales segundo porque
viven en comunidades donde hay una gran
contaminación los tanto los hispanos
como los afroamericanos son más
propensos en respirar aire sucio que es
precisamente lo que ha llevado a que
desarrollo de enfermedades respiratorias
que se han exacerbado precisamente con y
con el tema de el coronavirus
desigualdad económica de hecho el
presidente de donaldson hace poco firmó
una ley que desmantela una una ley
dentro dentro del departamento de
desarrollo urbano
el cual le permitía a esas comunidades
tener acceso a viviendas asequibles y
obviamente en muchas ciudades como aquí
en nueva york' de un ejemplo clarísimo
donde existe un desplazamiento de estas
comunidades de las ciudades porque
obviamente se vuelve más y más difícil
tener una vida más asequible y más
costeable yo concuerdo con las opiniones
de ambos de ambos invitados con el señor
que está en miami estoy totalmente de
acuerdo yo creo que joe biden no genera
las mismas pasiones que genera barack
obama pero si hay algún punto importante
para mencionar es que las personas yo
creo que no van a votar por yo bayern
por ser yo bailé sino porque no es
donald trump
yo creo que esta va a ser una de las uno
de los puntos que sale a sobresalir aquí
y otra otra observación que hago es lo
que también señalaba el invitado de
miami es que si escogieron acá de
manager es porque fue una jugada
magistral indudablemente y lo digo
porque yo bailen tal vez no tenga un
record
digamos favorable dentro de la comunidad
afroamericana porque el joe biden fue
una de las figuras que tal vez castigó a
anita hill sanitario en en los años 90
fue la primera mujer que salió
valientemente a denunciar a clarence
thomas que es el un juez de la corte
suprema afroamericano y que lo acusó de
acoso sexual y él tuvo un tono bastante
condescendiente con ella y obviamente
eso pues no caló muy bien dentro del
dentro de la comunidad de mujeres
afroamericanos así que yo creo que era
al traer a cavaliers que es una mujer
birracial tanto india como como negra
pues trata de resarcir un poco esa
herida que dejó aquel testimonio el
donde se enfrentó a anita hill con la
cámara o con el comité que estaba
llevando la investigación en aquel
entonces sí entonces esa era esa es mi
observación respecto a joe biden porque
obviamente como bueno mención del yo
creo que el haber escogido a camaná
harris pues fue una jugada ministerial
precisamente para tratar de conquistar
el voto el voto afroamericano si hay
algo que yo quisiera también agregar si
sería me tenés yo creo que
lo que hemos visto es eso también lo que
señala la invitada de mil votos si lo
que se procura con esta convención es de
tener un poco más de pluralidad
obviamente se habla de alexandre vacas
yo cortés y de manizales el ala más
progresista y más radical pero yo creo
que aquí se incorporan muchas voces y
donde se han incorporado también
distintos temas desde el cuidado
infantil hasta el digamos la brutalidad
policial y una reforma policial que es
necesaria en este país y esos son los
temas que se han tocado mientras que los
republicanos por lo menos lo que se
conoce de los dos a los que las personas
que van a intervenir la próxima semana
yo creo que los republicanos van a pelar
un poco más esa ley a lo que nosotros
conocemos aquí como la guerra de las
culturas porque ni siquiera se está
intentando llamar a demócratas que tal
vez concuerden con las ideas de donald
trump sino que se están amparando en
personas que han sido atacadas por lo
que se conoce aquí como la cultura de la
cancelación y podemos ahondar más en ese
tema más adelante
y para darle paso también a los otros
invitados así es robert vamos ahorita
precisamente en su misma ciudad donde se
encuentra nuestra corresponsable mamen
sala porque en este momento el
presidente de donald trump rompió la
tradición de no hacer actos de campaña
paralelos a la convención porque está
dando en este momento una entrevista al
canal foxnews mamen que dice el
presidente
pues si raúl como lo explicaba se ha
roto todas las tradiciones ya lo dijo ya
amenazó que a lo largo del día de hoy va
a hacer diferentes eventos de campaña o
en muy cerquita del pueblo de nación joe
biden para robar este protagonismo a los
demócratas en su último día de
convención y ahora mismo está ofreciendo
una entrevista a la cadena fox en la que
ha dicho que ha visto algunas partes de
la convención demócrata no mucho la
verdad por lo menos sabemos que seguro
que estuvo viendo ayer por la noche el
discurso de barack obama porque durante
el tiempo que el ex presidente daba el
discurso donald trump lanzaba algunos
tuits a través de su cuenta y ha dicho
bueno lo ha presentado el presentador le
ha dicho que si sabe que se está
hablando bastante de él en estos días y
ha dicho pues sí parece que sí es
interesante por esto que decía es porque
se ha saltado todas las tradiciones de
todas formas habrá que esperar a mañana
para ver si realmente su estrategia ha
surtido efecto o no sabemos que ayer
22,8 millones de estadounidenses
siguieron la jornada la tercera jornada
de la convención demócrata a través de
televisores mañana podremos ver qué ha
pasado realmente donald trump ha
conseguido su objetivo y también será
muy interesante ver cómo reaccionarán
los demócratas la semana que viene
cuando a la convención republicana de su
pistoletazo de salida el mismo lunes y
desde la ciudad de nueva york a mamen
vamos hasta washington de la capital
estadounidense con nuestra corresponsal
diana castañeda diana le pregunto cómo
llega el presidente de bailén a estas
elecciones y su fórmula y si su fórmula
vicepresidencial ya con jarvis puede
vencer a la del presidente de donald
trump compensa
bueno como lo mencionaba en algunos de
nuestros invitados la decisión de
nombrar a harris fue estratégica porque
no solamente representa a la comunidad
afroamericana pero también es hija de
inmigrantes y está abogando por
beneficios para los inmigrantes y justo
esto se da es uno de los temas que
mencionaba uno de nuestros invitados
cuando hay un momento muy importante en
la nación donde se registran protestas
continuas tras la muerte de georg floyd
meses atrás que se encadenó protestas y
todavía que en la capital de los eeuu
los fines de semana se registran
protestas del movimiento black lights
matters y es uno de los aspectos de los
que ha hablado no solo harris sino
también que van a impulsar que están
liderando los demócratas desde ya y es
una reforma al sistema policial de los
eeuu este es una iniciativa que están
adelantando los demócratas en la cámara
de representantes y si los demócratas
logran tener más miembros en el senado
logra darse esa transición pues tendrían
es poder de acción el presidente de
donald trump debido a la presión había
anunciado algunas medidas pero no una
reforma estructural y lo que busca el
partido demócrata en cabeza de bailén
sería una reforma en donde se dé un
presupuesto más amplio para tener más
fiscales que puedan investigar esos
incidentes criminales en donde se ven
en directo con el discurso de de cory
booker escuchamos
en las líneas de desempleo
y ese trabajo me permitió apoyar a su
familia y criar a mi madre y enviarle a
la universidad y ese es el sueño
estadounidense juntos trabajamos juntos
nos levantamos joe biden en cámara
harris conocen la dignidad de todos los
estadounidenses trabajadores y que saben
de la urgencia de nuestros sueños las
personas trabajadoras están bajo ataque
a la brecha de riqueza crece y la
pobreza persiste la semana pasada donald
trump dijo y sitios de nuestra economía
está muy bien mientras que 40 millones
de estadounidenses están en riesgo de
perder sus hogares 30 millones si no
tienen suficiente para comer y 5.4
millones de personas han perdido su
servicio de salud por culpa de esta
crisis
él ha fallado nos ha fallado pero aún
así tú y yo creo en el sueño de nuestros
ancestros
con joe y camada en la casa blanca
vamos a aumentar el salario mínimo
mínimo para que cualquier persona que
trabaje en eeuu nadie puede vivir en la
pobreza juntos
lucharemos por aquellos que nos
mantienen saludables que nos mantienen
seguros que enseñan a nuestros hijos nos
levantaremos por aquellos que cocinan y
sirven y limpia aquellos que
empaca y plantan aquellos que entregan
cuyas manos están llenas de callos como
las de mi abuelo quien me levantaba alto
cuando yo era un pequeño niño y vos si
estuviese vivo yo
él estaría tan orgulloso de ustedes y
toma a otro y a otro por la mano y ya
vamos a trabajar si quiere ser libre
tienes que trabajar por eso como su
generación nosotros saliendo desde la
depresión ahora trabajemos juntos y
mantengamos los juntos y eeuu juntos
vamos a levantarnos
y ustedes son quienes construyen eeuu
una esposa que trabaja gracias a
asegurarnos que sea seguro poder volver
a trabajar el trabajo después de ocho
semanas por fuera y aquí es dónde
estamos ahora bueno te digo que el
futuro de otro que está en eeuu y no
podría ser tan brillante como pudo haber
sido en los años 40 ya lo tenía entonces
parte de lo que está ocurriendo en este
momento en la convención demócrata en
eeuu y previamente a eso que estaban
viendo ustedes en pantalla estaba el
discurso del senador por new yersey cory
booker y quiero retomar con nuestra
corresponsal en washington dc diana
castañeda dian entonces hablemos un poco
del discurso de booker y lo que estamos
hablando previo
al senador
si estábamos hablando de que la reforma
al sistema policial será también uno de
los temas centrales que liderará no sólo
los vaivén sino también los demócratas
en la cámara de representantes sin
importar quién llegue a la casa blanca
en el 2021 y con cory booker veíamos a
una de las figuras más importantes del
partido demócrata una de las figuras
también más jóvenes y dinámicas que
llegó hasta cierto punto en las
primarias y que tiene mucha influencia
al interior del partido también porque
representa a esta minoría importante en
el país que es la minoría afroamericana
y por eso también veremos durante esta
noche así como en este discurso un tema
central que él mencionaba y es el
incremento al salario mínimo a la hora
este pago subirlo a 15 dólares y es uno
de los temas que durante la
administración del presidente de donald
trump no se vio digamos un mayor impulso
sólo en ciertos estados y esto es algo
que vaivén lo quiere hacer a nivel
nacional sí que lleguen los estados a
tener que discutirlo sin que tenga que
llegar a pasar por un proceso más
sino para que haya una ayuda inmediata
sobre todo en medio de la crisis por el
coronavirus también uno de los temas que
de los que se espera hablar en esta
noche serán los beneficios en materia de
empleo y beneficios de recuperación
económica y pequeños negocios a los que
puedan acceder cualquier estadounidense
sin importar su estatus migratorio y
esto porque durante la administración
del presidente de donald trump quedaron
por fuera de los cheques de estímulo
estos cheques que el presidente enviaba
con una carta y con su nombre por 1.200
dólares sólo podían aplicar residentes y
ciudadanos así que una gran cantidad de
inmigrantes incluso inmigrantes legales
con visas y calificados no pudieron
aplicar y es uno de los demás que ha
dicho el partido demócrata el
coronavirus no discrimina y por lo tanto
la ayuda del gobierno federal debería
llegar a todos los ciudadanos diana
gracias y me voy nuevamente a la ciudad
de miami con el señor ron aledo analista
político y de seguridad de estratega
republicano quiero retomar un poco
estaba hablando el señor valència en la
ciudad de nueva york que él decía que a
lo mejor las personas que no estaban muy
convencidos de esta fórmula harris
baiden no iban a votar por ellos sino
para no votar por el presidente donald
trump que busca su reelección este 3 de
noviembre y le preguntó entonces cómo ha
funcionado el voto castigo
tradicionalmente en eeuu
bueno el asunto simplemente para de
bailén está intentando asegurarse el
gran centro está tratando de mostrarse
como moderado él sabe que esas personas
que posiblemente no tengan mucha pasión
por él ni estén detrás de él
especialmente los jóvenes universitarios
los jóvenes más idealistas que sí eran
los que apoyaban muchísimo a bernie
sanders y son los que están como leandro
que se corten o tengan una motivación
por el grande
pero ellos quieren que mira tienen que
votar por mí porque no tienen otra
opción si no votan por mí tienen a trono
o sea que aunque no estén con emoción y
convicción ni quieran hacerlo de una
manera ideológica lo van a hacer por
necesidad o sea que ellos creen que es a
la izquierdista ya la tienen en el
bolsillo sin emoción sin pasión pero que
la tienen asegurada entonces vice de los
que está tratando de hacer ahora mismo
es tratar de ganar el centro
el centro de balance el centro de los
votantes en mostrarse como moderado y
tratar de no dar mucho brillo ni mucho
espacio al ala más izquierdista ahora
bien yo creo que lo va a tener muy
difícil vaivenes a mi opinión yo
recomiendo a todos que lean throne la
escuela de frankfurt y la
contrarrevolución en mi artículo que
escribí en el 2016 cuando ganó tromba
están en español y en inglés
trong la escuela de france la
contrarrevolución ahí explicó que la
victoria de trump fue una revolución
cultural fue una revolución de la
américa profunda de la américa
silenciosa la mayoría silenciosa que se
mantenía aislada que se mantenía fuera
de las cámaras de televisión y de los
medios y de las élites de los neocon es
y de los globalistas republicanos
también que están ahora apoyando a baile
que no tenían nada que ver con esas
uniones globalistas que no tenían nada
que ver con las élites del partido
demócrata personas que estaban furiosas
o que estaban cansadas de qué
obama le impusieron una ideología de que
obama le pusiera a hombre vestido de
mujer en los baños con sus niñas para
que impusiera matrimonio entre
homosexuales que le pusieran abortos
a largo término tardío a personas que le
estaban empujando cosas que iba a
encontrar su cultura en contra de su
formación bíblica su formación religiosa
de su formación cultural y esa américa
profunda que en realidad eran los
demócratas de reagan que llevaban 30
años fuera del partido republicano se
sintieron otra vez en casa control y
volvieron otra vez al partido
republicano después de abandonarlo
después de 30 años los demócratas de
reagan volvieron al partido republicano
y se han mantenido ahí un fenómeno que
no había pasado ni con bush y con romney
ni con nadie más y yo creo que el trump
va a tratar otra vez de conseguir esa
mayoría silenciosa esa mayoría de la
américa profunda esos demócratas de
reagan que vinieron al partido
republicano gracias a él después de 30 a
35 años fuera del partido y creo que va
a mantener eso iba a utilizar va se va a
presentar como la gente de ley y orden
hacer lo mismo que hizo nixon en el 68
rayos del 68 los desórdenes del 68
ayudaron mucho a nixon y yo creo que esa
es la estrategia de tron para este año
que es presentarse como la del partido
demócrata bait del kamala harris han
abandonado a nuestros héroes ha
abandonado a la policía han abandonado a
los que nos defienden y protegen yo no
voy a hacer eso yo voy a seguir con la
policía son nuestros héroes y una o dos
manzanas podridas aquí no representan a
la policía ni de nueva york ni de
chicago ni de los ángeles y muchísimo
menos yo estoy con la policía esto con
ciudadano de a pie con jon 2 estoy con
la gente de la calle y ese va a ser el
problema de byron bay le va a tener un
gran problema a ganarse esos esos
demócratas de reagan que están hoy día
en control a ganarse al américa a la
media la américa profunda al américa de
a pie que va a adaptar el control por
cuestiones culturales ideológicas me va
a parecer que vais de níjar y vas a
tener un gran problema en ganarse los
esto en noviembre
gracias por su opinión ahora quiero ver
y con el del señor o valència en la
ciudad de nueva york el señor aledo
hablaba de esta revolución cultural que
auto entonces en el 2016 por el
presidente donald trump cansaba lo mejor
de una administración de barack obama
que duró ocho años en el poder porque
pues obviamente tuvo una doble
presidencia luego de ser reelecto señor
valencia pero le quiero preguntar si
entonces no podemos ver lo mismo de que
pase esa misma revolución pero el otro
lado gente que está cansada del discurso
del presidente donald trump de a lo
mejor de confrontación y todos estos
movimientos sociales que han surgido en
esto en estos últimos meses
en el país esa no se pueden ir sumando
más votos para para que esa revolución
cultural como decía el señor aledo pase
pero contra donald trump
yo creo que bueno yo lo que veo es lo
siguiente que basándonos en lo que hemos
visto hasta el momento en la convención
demócrata aquí lo que veremos la próxima
semana
los demócratas han tratado de hacerlo
más pluralista posible desde cómo se
dice el ala más recalcitrante del
partido demócrata con la invitación de
bernie sanders y de alexandre o casi
cortes la invitación de la familia de
tony lloyd para ser parte de esta es
también esta convención y un sinnúmero
de personalidades de todo tipo de rango
mientras que los republicanos por lo
menos aún a juzgar por la lista
preliminar de los de las personas que
van a hablar pues va a ser como menciona
precisamente el invitado es simplemente
yo creo que el otro no tiene tal vez el
interés de llegar a un grupo de personas
urbanas progresistas que ya básicamente
tienen decidido por quién van a votar y
se va a enfocar precisamente en lo que
se conoce como esa guerra cultural el de
llegar al estadounidense
como rural que digamos tiene vamos a
decirlo temor porque eso se ha tratado
de hecho un reporte del new york times'
e hizo un análisis desde iowa en donde
las familias evangélicas que son más
tradicionales pues tienen una relación
transaccional con donald trump porque
ellos dicen que cuando mi ídolo cuando
me gusta porque tiene un lenguaje
bastante procaz es muy shoes le pone
apodos a todo el mundo sin embargo él es
mi salvaguardia él es la persona que va
a defender mi cultura va a defender mi
religión y me va a proteger de esas
personas como es el invitado de esas
personas que quieren imponer una
ideología de género si quiere llamar de
esa manera visitó precisamente porque el
día de hoy en el discurso que donald
trump yo en en pensilvania habla
precisamente de eso llegar a ese grupo
de personas que se ven amenazadas y que
básicamente lo que ha hecho el presiente
otra vez utilizar el miedo
para llegar a esas personas y si todo lo
que dijo él el día de hoy en este
fragmento de pensilvania dijo ellos no
quieren cancelar hablando de la cultura
de la cancelación totalmente cancelado
tomar su trabajo y voltear el digamos
poner su familia en contra tuya por de
expresar su opinión mientras que en
doctrina nuestros niños
con ideas mundiales o globales torcidas
que nadie pensó posible cuando nosotros
leemos ese discurso precisamente eso es
lo que va a tratar de hacer tono trama
de crear una división mientras que los
demócratas intentan por lo menos
incorporar todo un crisol de razas y de
ideas como lo hemos visto nuestros
cuatro días y obviamente yo creo que la
administración de don chon es ese va a
ser el enfoque el blanco de lo del
suburbio que prácticamente fue el que le
dio el triunfo a donald trump y en eso
es que se va a enfocar no tanto en las
ideas sino básicamente en infundir un
miedo
dentro de una población que todavía creo
que yo no comprende o por lo menos no
asimila que hay un cambio demográfico en
estados unidos y en donde nosotros los
hispanos seremos la mayoría en el año
2050 y en donde muchas de las nuevas
generaciones tienden a ser un poco más
progresistas que la vieja guardia de los
boomers que la generación x si se quiere
llamar y vamos entrando en una
transición generacional donde los
millennials que vengo siendo yo
los la generación z que es un poco más
progresista y un poco más tolerante con
temas de inmigración con el tema de
digamos de la igualdad racial de los
derechos reproductivos etcétera etcétera
etcétera pero yo creo que vamos a ver si
esta convención que logran tratar de
incorporar el que procura incorporar en
distintas corrientes ideológicas y
geográficas de eeuu logra conquistar
el electorado que se ha visto inconforme
porque mientras que bill o mientras que
en el 2016 pero básicamente un referendo
al establecimiento y concuerdo también
con el imitador que es provider pues no
representa el anti establishment como se
conoce a quien eeuu pero aquí veremos si
es una un referendo también a una
administración de donación que aunque
mantuvo un ritmo económico bastante
saludable lamentablemente su falta de
preparación para enfrentar la pandemia
le está pasando factura y es en el
momento en que vemos 170 mil fallecidos
más de 5 millones de infectados y cerca
como lo acabo de mencionar un 26% un 26
por ciento de desempleados dentro de la
comunidad hispana que es básicamente la
que más una de las medidas que más se ha
visto afectada lamentablemente por esta
falta de acción que fue una acción
bastante tardía y donde el presidente
from tal vez podría haber
tomado un liderazgo distinto pero
lamentablemente en estos en estas
alocuciones que tenía de ser a
casablanca en el momento más difícil de
la pandemia pues prefirió jugar a la
política insultar a los nuevos de
comunicación y de promover incluso la
inyección de clorox y de desinfectar
antes en los en de forma intravenosa y
obviamente pues eso yo creo que está
también pasando factura porque por lo
menos hay una ligera desventaja se
enfrenta una ligera desventaja ante ante
joe biden y por lo menos en la
predilección del electorado pero bueno
vamos a ver qué ocurre en estos próximos
meses porque yo creo que todavía la
pelea está un poco cerrada pero pero
vamos a ver cómo se desempeñan ambos
ambas campañas así es robert y hablando
de votos y electorado quiero preguntarle
a maría fernanda en la ciudad de
milwaukee el voto latino para para dónde
va a estar más encaminado para los
demócratas o para los republicanos con
el presidente con el presidente de
donald trump y como a lo mejor hacer los
demócratas en el caso de que tengan una
desventaja para sumar la mayoría de los
votos
creo que
pero todavía pues las cartas están en el
aire
y si bien hubo este apoyo de los latinos
a donald trump más apoyo del que se
pensaba que iba a tener por parte de los
latinos dadas sus palabras y sus
comentarios hacia los mexicanos y hacia
los países latinoamericanos sobre todos
los países centroamericanos que que
mandan inmigrantes a eeuu
a pesar de sus políticas duras de
inmigración y su deseo de construir un
muro es no se puede negar que existe
apoyo por parte de la comunidad latina
al presidente de chrome
este sin embargo hay muchos latinos que
también este quieren ver un regreso a la
normalidad
las cartas están en el aire hemos visto
en estos días en estas noches de las
convenciones que los demócratas han
querido enfatizar a los grupos
minoritarios
la noche de ayer hubo una fue
predominantemente mujeres las que las
que hablaron también hemos visto mucho
énfasis en los en el grupo afroamericano
no tanto el grupo latino yo creo que el
grupo latino siempre es un enigma para
para los tanto los que hacen encuestas
como los los candidatos porque el grupo
latino en eeuu
muchas veces no no vota es un grupo que
es difícil de éste
de engage como es en inglés de
interactuar no es no hay te actual pero
de llevarlos a las urnas ya sea por pues
no sé por algunas veces la mayoría de
los de los gamers por ejemplo que no
tienen papeles o que no quieren abrir a
los censos es un grupo muy difícil de
llevar a las urnas y no se ha visto un
un trabajo de
un trabajo de d
atraer a los latinos y de movilizarlos
es un grupo que no es para nada
monolítico es un grupo minoritario pero
que va a llegar a ser de mayor mayor
proporción de eeuu como decía robert
valencia este en 30 años más o menos va
a tener una mayoría hispana
hispanoparlantes y es un grupo que con
cada elección toma más y más peso pero
es un grupo que no por eso se vuelve más
fácil de descifrar o más fácil de decir
de de engage de captar claro que si
maría fernanda ahora quiero ir entonces
con nuestra corresponsal en la ciudad de
nueva york mamen sala mamen hablando del
voto latino cómo está el voto latino en
nueva york' y además le quiero preguntar
cómo llega by den a estas elecciones
sí bueno aquí no mayor tenemos que tener
en cuenta que más del 80 por ciento de
la población es demócrata la mayoría de
los latinos que viven aquí en nueva york
votan por el partido demócrata y sí que
tenemos que pensar también que estoy
completamente de acuerdo con los
anteriores contertulios con que no se
les está dando el peso que igual se les
debería dar esta noche pocas voces de
representantes latinos vamos a encontrar
en general en líneas generales yo creo
que en el punto de vista latino se
debería apostar mucho más y en cuanto a
la idea en esta noche pues bueno vamos a
ver es interesante también que así como
las noches anteriores escuchábamos un
poquito más lo que se va a hacer en
cuestiones de política esta noche por
ejemplo estamos viendo más la parte más
humana el para que del carácter de
bailén a través de pues eso pues lo que
hemos dicho personas que están hablando
sobre él y esos vídeos que estamos
viendo y que veremos de sus hijos y
nietos que nos lo van a describir nos
van a describir ese baile más humano y
ese
que le ha llevado toda su vida que
precisamente le van a servir para poder
sacar adelante esta nación si es
reelegir si es elegido presidente así es
también si en este momento también
estábamos viendo en pantalla el homenaje
al hijo de joe biden que era militar y
pues también murió una de las pérdidas
también que han sacado los demócratas a
flote en esta en esta convención
diciendo que va a tener a una persona
que entendía era una persona empática
era una persona que se ha sabido
levantar durante todas sus tragedias y
vamos a ver entonces un poco del
ambiente lo que ocurre precisamente en
ese momento en la convención demócrata
con este homenaje al hijo de joe biden
pide a formar
[Música]
y un poco del ambiente de lo que ocurría
en esa línea de lo que ocurre en este
momento en esa convención demócrata
donde se espera el plato fuerte de la
noche por supuesto las palabras de
giovannini también un discurso de
pittsburgh ets que fue el precandidato
presidencial también por el partido
demócrata abiertamente homosexual de la
comunidad lgtb y también hablan un poco
de las minorías de la cual hablábamos y
entonces antes del discurso quiero dar
una antesala a lo mejor con nuestro
invitado robert valencia en la ciudad de
nueva york y le quiero preguntar qué
vaivén se acerca entonces de esta manera
y con el discurso de pury hecha la
comunidad lgtb y cuáles son las
necesidades actuales de esta comunidad
en eeuu
bueno yo toqué si yo no soy ex no soy
experto
vamos a escuchar a buried precisamente y
después hablamos sobre el discurso
y el cargo y en un informe
cuando cuál es tu vida en riesgo por
este país y no por qué es el país dónde
vives sino porque es un país en el cual
crees
yo creo en este país porque eeuu
mantener la promesa de un lugar donde
todo el mundo puede pertenecer nosotros
sabemos que para muchos y durante mucho
tiempo de esa promesa ha sido denegadas
pero también sabemos que eeuu está en su
mejor momento cuando hacemos que ese
círculo de pertenencia sea más amplio
hace diez años yo me uní a las fuerzas
militares donde despedirme por quién era
yo no solamente era posible sino que era
una política ahora en 2020 es ilegal en
eeuu despedir a alguien por quién es o
por quién ama
el anillo de una boda que celebramos
aquí donde estoy parado en este momento
refleja como este país puede cambiar el
amor y hace que mi matrimonio sea real
pero el coraje político lo hizo posible
incluyendo el de joe biden
quien estuvo por delante de este partido
cuando dijo que la actividad para el
matrimonio debería ser ley aún queda
mucho por hacer pero decir tanto puede
cambiar entre el 2010 y el 2020 imaginen
lo que podría cambiar entre ahora y 2030
imaginen lo que podríamos lograr con
esta coalición que estamos construyendo
en esta temporada con progresistas
moderados independientes e incluso los
que yo llamo los futuros ex republicanos
dependiendo en eeuu donde todo el mundo
pertenezca joe biden está en lo correcto
este es un contexto y una lucha por el
alma de esta nación y para mí esa pelea
no es entre los buenos y los malos
es una lucha para señalar lo que es
bueno en cada uno de nosotros depende de
nosotros ser a eeuu un lugar donde la fe
se trate de sanar y no de excluir
podemos convertirnos en un país que
respete la verdad de que las vidas
negras importan donde podamos
mantenerlas los temas médicos y de
ciencias
con los científicos y doctores
donde nadie que trabaje a tiempo
completo puede vivir en la pobreza yo
confío en yo y en cámara harris para que
nos lleven hacia ese futuro mejor porque
he visto de cerca su empatía y su
capacidad así como he visto a mis la
capacidad mis compatriotas para
incluirse a unos a otros y hacer lo
mejor por la promesa de eeuu cuando yo
nací la idea del fin candidato buscando
un cargo
era algo visible pero ahora yo hice la
campaña para ser presidente con mi
esposo ganando delegados hasta esta
misma convención ahora vengo a esta
convención apoyando con orgullo by denny
cámara jarosz muriéndome a demócratas
con quienes estaba en competencia hace
apenas unos meses hace poco nos reunimos
para hablar del show que conocemos
hola a todos estoy muy orgulloso de
presentarles a todos un grupo de
personas que compitió en la primaria en
contra de iovine pueden pensar en este
tour como survivor sin las entrevistas y
con todas las personas que se fueron de
la isla
no te rías porque ahí de an entonces
usted es el ambiente de esta convención
demócrata en su último día esperando las
palabras de joe biden ya como candidato
a la presidencia por su partido también
estábamos escuchando previamente
al ex alcalde de south bend indiana y
también precandidato presidencial por el
partido demócrata bourget si antes
de esto estaba conversando con robert
valència robert hablando de las minorías
específicamente a lo mejor de la
comunidad tlgb y en eeuu cuáles son las
necesidades que tiene actualmente esta
comunidad
si estaba mencionando que aunque yo
tengo que reconocer que no soy un
experto necesariamente en el tema del
gtp pero sí sé que esta comunidad
enfrenta a un reto particularmente con
protecciones a nivel laboral hay 31
estados que todavía no han pasado leyes
que les permitan protegerse de cualquier
tipo de discriminación en el trabajo o
en la fuerza laboral otro tema que
también es importante mencionar es que
está en grupo también enfrenta retos y
no necesariamente exclusivos pero si
tienen un tienen retos particulares
cuando se trata del cuidado de la salud
y como lo hemos visto desde
prácticamente el comienzo de la
administración de donald trump lo que ha
intentado esta administración es de
desmantelar el obama crear que igual no
domine su camino habíamos mencionado que
en algún momento en esta emisión y no
solamente perjudica a la comunidad lgtb
sino que también perjudica a una gran
parte del país
de hecho aún en medio de la pandemia eso
es lo que estaba tratando de hacer el
presidente de donald trump desmantelar
ciertas digamos ciertas provisiones del
obamacare en medio de una pandemia
cuando hay 41 digamos en abril por lo
menos o entre abril y mayo habían 45
millones de desempleados como ustedes
saben aquí el sistema funciona que uno
tiene un seguro médico a través de un
empleado y de la única manera para poder
tener acceso médico asequible es
inscribiéndose a obama care en este caso
sin necesidad de tener un patrón o un
empleador entonces imagínense
desmantelar el un seguro como el de
obama que en medio de una pandemia pues
hubiera sido totalmente catastrófico y
aún así eso nunca detuvo al creciente
donald trump en su intento por destripar
esta ley y esos son también las los
retos que enfrenta la comunidad lgtb en
donde muchos de ellos pues no tienen
acceso
con cuidado de salud asequible y
universal que es también lo que hablaba
incluso cory booker en el caso de los
hispanos en medio de una pandemia
veíamos que la administración de donald
trump obligó a muchos frigoríficos a
abrir a mantenerse abierto para atender
la demanda por productos cárnicos aquí
en eeuu y muchos de esos trabajadores
eran hispanos
y no tenía seguro médico y la menta de
lo que lo que hemos visto
lamentablemente es que una de las uno de
los grupos más afectados dentro de la
comunidad hispana en el tema de la salud
son el campesinado quienes tal vez uno
si no es el grupo más importante porque
es prácticamente el que mantiene la
cadena de suplemento de suministro de
alimentos y aún así muchas de esas
personas se han enfermado y han muerto
por causa de la corona bien así que yo
creo que eso es ese para mí sería uno de
los grandes retos no solamente para la
comunidad lgtb en el tema del cuidado
médico sino para muchos de nosotros
también que vemos hemos visto como esta
administración
procura no desmantelar el obamacare sin
siquiera tener un plan alternativo que
tal vez mejore las condiciones de la
salud pública a quien eeuu señora leo
quiero ir con ustedes en la ciudad de
miami en el estado de la florida y
preguntarle entonces cómo está
actualmente el país como está
actualmente en eeuu bajo la
administración del presidente dentro de
materia
los derechos para la comunidad lgtb y
para las minorías
bueno la comunidad homosexual y
transgénero
obviamente están con el partido
demócrata obviamente
son las personas menos religiosas los
palos más probatorios más secularistas
bernie sanders es la plataforma más
liberal de las grandes ciudades y
obviamente hay que recordar hay que ver
que hay que tomar los elementos de
juicio las hipótesis y hay que
combinarla cuando yo era analista en la
cia eso era lo que hacíamos en la cia
hacer el análisis de la competencia
hipótesis para llegar a conclusiones y
aquí la hipótesis y aquí la realidad de
esta situación es que las elecciones
presiones legales de eeuu si lo
interrumpo para escuchar a a michael
bloomberg y vuelvo con usted adelante
uno cree en los hechos el otro no
escucha los expertos el otro cree que
sabe todo
uno mira hacia el futuro y ve fortaleza
en la diversidad estadounidense el otro
es mirar hacia atrás y ve a los
inmigrantes como amigos y a los blancos
supremacistas como aliados hay otras
diferencias uno ha probado que sabe cómo
manejar una crisis ayudando a liderar la
reforma económica después de la recesión
del 2008 mientras que el otro no
solamente ha fallado al liberar sino que
ha hecho que la crisis actual sea mucho
peor enfrentado a la mayor calamidad que
ningún presidente se han prestado en la
era moderna
ignoró la ciencia y ahí ignoró la
amenaza mucho y recomendó curas falsas
lo que hizo que el joven se extendiera
de manera mucho más rápida dejando a
miles enfermos o muertos le ha fallado
al pueblo estadounidense de manera
catastrófica hace cuatro años yo vine a
esta convención
que los lorquinos conocemos a una
persona como la cuando la vemos no les
pido que voten en contra de él porque
sea malo sino porque ha hecho un trabajo
terrible el desempleo está en su nivel
más alto y los pequeños negocios están
luchando para sobrevivir no tenía que
ser así
antes de que me lanzara a la alcaldía
pasé 20 años dirigiendo un nuevo negocio
que comenzó de cero entonces quiero
pedirles a los pequeños negociantes y a
los empleados una pregunta hacerles una
sola pregunta ustedes se recontrataría o
trabajarían para alguien que acabó con
sus negocios y que hace lo mejor que es
para él incluso si va en contra de la
compañía y cuyas decisiones los ponen en
peligro y que pasan más tiempo enviando
tweets que trabajando si la respuesta es
no entonces por qué demonios re
contrataríamos a donald trump por otros
cuatro años cuando dice que deberíamos
soportar por él porque son
un hombre de negocios en serio se llevó
a sus compañías seis veces a la
bancarrota dejando atrás a los clientes
y a los contratistas que terminaron y no
volvieron a hacer negocios con él ahora
muchos de nosotros estamos pagando ese
precio y no podemos permitir que se
salga con la suya donde dice que
deberíamos votar por él porque la
economía estaba muy bien antes del virus
que biden y obama crearon más empleos en
los últimos tres años que la
administración top hizo en sus primeros
tres y el crecimiento económico era más
alto bajo obama y bailén que bajó 8 de
hecho lo que ayudó a salvar un millón de
empleos de la industria automotriz todo
lo contrario cuando chang dice que
quiere que quiere hacer eeuu grande de
nuevo esta vez en un gran caso para joe
biden nuestro objetivo no debería ser
traer de vuelta la economía de antes de
la pandemia sino reconstruir la mejor
como dice el plan económico de yo va a
crear empleos de energía limpia que
ayudará
y evitar otra crisis climática va a
reconstruir nuestros puentes y nuestras
rutas algo de lo que no ha hablado pero
que en los últimos tres años no ha hecho
absolutamente nada que farsa y déjeme
decirle un secreto el plan
fue darle un recorte de impuestos a
personas como yo que no lo necesitábamos
y después mentirle a todo el mundo bueno
yo va a acabar con esta reducción
impuestos que yo obtuve para que podamos
financiar cosas que necesitamos como
entrenamientos para los adultos que han
perdido empleos y hacer que la
universidad sea más asequible
invertir en desarrollo para que los
productos del mañana sean hechos por
trabajadores estadounidenses creciendo
me enseñaron que eeuu es el mejor país
del mundo no porque ganamos la segunda
guerra mundial sino porque la luchamos
por la libertad por la democracia y por
la equidad
sobre un niño que se une después de la
revolución industrial al final del libro
y ve a una nación que está verde soñando
por el futuro este es el eeuu que yo
conozco y que amo y eso es en eeuu que
podemos perder con este presidente
entonces pongamos un fin a todo este
capítulo triste en la historia
estadounidense y vamos a elegir líderes
que van a traer estabilidad y
competencia de vuelta a la casa blanca
joe y cámara vayan ponemos por todos
nosotros
y genial y lo tenían ustedes en pantalla
era michael bloomberg era ex alcalde de
la ciudad de nueva york empresario
multimillonario estadounidense y también
participó en la precandidatura para esta
carrera a la casa blanca de este año
antes de bloomberg estábamos hablando y
ya para cerrar el tema entonces de las
minorías y de la comunidad tlgb te
importante también para el partido
demócrata estábamos hablando con el
señor aliado del señor aledo en la
ciudad de miami tiene usted nuevamente
la palabra
y bueno yo decía que hay que analizar a
nivel macro que era lo que yo hacía
cuando estaba en la cia con uno era
analista allí y hay que hay que tomar en
las elecciones de eeuu analizando la y
todas las hipótesis en eeuu como dije ya
en los homosexuales y trasciende siempre
vamos a votar demócrata de hecho todas
las costas siempre van a votar demócrata
todas las grandes ciudades de las
izquierdas donde las izquierdas siempre
van a votar demócrata
el para el béisbol bell
señora le escuchamos ok
de las noticias
si escuchamos adelante el golpe al sur
de eeuu siempre por los republicanos por
religiosos últimos de la ley moral
natural
por todas las situaciones que siempre
ayudan a las religiosas y morales que
necesiten las elecciones de eeuu
internos de los estados
púrpuras éstos destinan para un lado
para otro todos obreros de pensilvania
de ohio y wisconsin michigan estos son
respetados que de verdad existen las
elecciones y lo que va a ser tron va a
ser ganarse otra vez a ese electorado el
rostro del solo decisivo tu hombro que
va a ser lo que tiene que contrarrestar
by the noise es el apoyo que tiene en
ese rosbel de esos demócratas de riga
que abandonaron el partido republicano
cuando arriban se retiró estuvieron con
los demócratas por los últimos 30 años
pero han vuelto otra vez por culpa de
trono al partido republicano
spider tiene que enfrentarse a eso hay
una cosa importante que la gente en eeuu
tiene miedo tiene miedo a que tan
extremista pueda ser el partido
demócrata a qué tanto pueda ser país
una marioneta de la estable en del
partido demócrata porque el partido
demócrata empezó derribando estatuas
confederadas y terminó derribando
estatua de cristóbal colón en por timor
y destruyendo tratando de destruir
estatuas de juan ponce de león
de san luís la ciudad de san luis
sanluis radio santo católico porque
lleva su nombre la ciudad y tienes miedo
a todo eso querían últimamente hasta
estaban criticando las estatuas de jesús
y maría en las iglesias porque eran muy
blancas entonces la gente de a pie de la
américa profunda tiene miedo a esta
radicalización extrema cultural y de
trump va a aprovechar especialmente la
américa profunda en el por paul weltz
para aprovechar para ganar contra contra
by de una cosa muy importante el hispano
el latino de las grandes ciudades de
miami
el sur del bronx
el uptown manhattan el salvadoreño del
norte de virginia esto siempre son de
izquierdas siempre son de izquierdas
siempre están de izquierda van a votar
por el que les dé más ayudas sociales
para conocer más de los legalice
ilegales que pueden realizarse lo legal
y práctico pero es dispar y trabaja de
obrero en el róster de trabajo explica
que hay ellos y dicen que van por vida
la cultura regional desde el sitio
abandona la cultura clásica
esa cultura regional importante es ir a
la iglesia de denver
ahora trabajo en china eso es lo
importante
allí
sus primos
es difícil para mí tienes ahora gana ese
voto decisivo en las elecciones eso va a
ser el problema porque ahora se tiene
que posicionar
está a favor o no está
efe
americano
definirse está a favor o no del amor
total a favor de las niñas
por su apoyo al aborto y el cardenal lo
apoyo
[Música]
sra entonces gracias por su opinión y
quiero y entonces cambiar un poco de
tema e ir también con algo que parece
curioso en esta convención porque muchos
de los que criticaban a joe biden ahora
les están apoyando como michael
bloomberg y precisamente quiero ir a
donde él fue exalcalde a la ciudad de
nueva york a nuestra corresponsal
comensal a mamen
si es interesante también raúl que
estamos hablando de un ex republicano
convertido que como decías durante estas
primarias no fue precisamente uno de los
grandes fans de joe biden de hecho se le
ha criticado mucho su participación como
speaker como orador en esta convención
pues porque muchos dicen que bueno que
al final habrá donado mucho dinero al
partido pero nunca directamente a bailén
y de hecho cuando él decidió terminar su
candidatura en esas primarias que vimos
se suponía que todo su equipo iba a
pasar a trabajar con él
con el candidato yo bailé y nunca lo
cumplió despidiendo a muchísimos
trabajadores pero es interesante porque
hoy ha venido aquí a hablar de economía
por petición precisamente de joe biden
porque el candidato al final pues confía
en que él va a poder plantear la
economía de la manera que interesa a los
demócratas y es que hay que tener mucho
cuidado cuando se entra en el tema de la
economía porque hoy en día las encuestas
siguen dando o siguen dando un triunfo a
donald trump cuando se habla de economía
y de empleo a pesar de la pandemia en la
que nos encontramos y a pesar de que él
interior bruto anual de este país esté
casi al 33 ha decaído casi un 33 por
ciento y eso que podría incluso ir a
peor con el cierre de varias empresas
después del repunte de casos de
coronavirus que hemos visto en varios
estados entonces es interesante que le
haya elegido a él para hablar de
economía es interesante también que se
le ha dado mucho más tiempo que al resto
de sus opositores en esas primarias
incluso en el horario de máxima
audiencia que es precisamente esta
segunda hora recordemos que por ejemplo
sin ir más lejos hillary clinton tuvo
menos tiempo ya bro habló en la primera
bloomberg desde luego ha sido pues como
decías no el mejor amigo para ello va a
ir en pero desde luego un gran
benefactor para el partido que ha donado
muchísimo dinero y como decíamos
anteriormente haya anunciado que donará
otros 60 millones de dólares solamente
para enfrentarse a donald trama así que
supongo que esto también ha sido un
motivo de peso para que en esta
convención pues se le haya dado voz
diezma me quedo en su ciudad de nacida
de nueva york para ir con nuestro otro
invitado el señor robert valencia y le
quiero preguntar por las ventajas reales
que tiene bites en contra donald trump
para poder ganar esta campaña electoral
de cara a las elecciones del 3 de
noviembre y por supuesto ganar las
elecciones
aunque quisiera hacer un par de
apreciaciones con el comentario anterior
respecto a la composición
y demográfica hispana estoy totalmente
de acuerdo porque los hispanos no son un
grupo monolítico pero decir que los
hispanos que viven en el sur de de nueva
york de donde prácticamente donde yo
radico o las personas que viven en el
norte de virginia como son los
salvadoreños que simplemente estamos
esperando que un candidato les dé cosas
gratis o que estén en lo que se conoce
como un sistema del welfare juego
este proyecto que les permiten a darles
subsidios y caracterizar caracterizarlo
de esa manera me parece que es un poco
peligroso también y me parece que es
hasta cierta manera pues no me parece
que sea una apreciación es certera
realmente si bien los hispanos se
preocupan por el tema de la economía no
es para que les regalen todo yo creo que
esa es una percepción que me parece que
se tiene que eliminar si hay un grupo
que está preocupado por obtener trabajos
y trabajos dignos son los hispanos yo no
que obviamente pues habrá uno que otro
rapero pero caracterizar
a una comunidad por por algún tema
anecdótico me parece que no es de
apreciar
y en el tema de las estados y todo esto
bueno pues obviamente hay personas que
estarán en desacuerdo por la destrucción
de las propiedades
robert pero decir que ciudadanos
estadounidenses están escandalizados
pues si el movimiento blu-ray smarter
está apoyado por más de 20 millones de
personas desde la muerte de georg floyd
y es tal vez el movimiento civil más
grande de la historia los 2000 pero creo
que va a hablar y están igual de cisa
mente los hijos de dubai en asia y
hunter va a escuchar es un momento y
volvemos a nuestro a nuestro análisis y
discusión
y tratar a todos con respeto sin
importar quién sea usted no importa
cuántas veces se haya caído será el peor
enemigo de cualquier bully será el mejor
amigo que jamás tendrá los amará con
todo su corazón y si les da su número de
teléfono
nos va a llamar como lo sabemos porque
ha sido así toda la vida y ha sido un
gran padre y creemos que será un gran
presidente evo ya no está con nosotros
pero aún está vivo en nuestros corazones
y podemos escuchar su voz fuerte como si
fuera ayer como si fuera ayer en 2008 y
en 2012 él presentó a nuestro padre en
esas convenciones y decisiones tuviera
claramente sabríamos lo que dirías
entonces antes de mostrarle una película
sobre
nuestro padre que hable
[Aplausos]
en momentos públicos y privados es el
padre que siempre ha conocido el abuelo
que mis hijos adoran y aman mi padre mi
héroe joe biden
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y entonces eran parte de las
declaraciones de los hijos del candidato
joe biden ashly hunter y bow del hijo
que falleció y antes de eso estamos
hablando con con robert valencia de
relación de nueva york robert leroy
nuevamente la palabra esperando pues el
discurso del candidato by the end y
posiblemente vamos a tener un pero
nuevamente pero adelante por ahora
si simplemente quería hacer un poquito
de aclaración en el tema de de las
percepciones que se tienen dentro de
ciertos grupos hispanos en eeuu y de tal
vez tener un poco de cuidado en señalar
que hayan salvadoreños o puertorriqueños
que simplemente estén viviendo de los
subsidios me parece que hay que tener un
poco de cuidado y de juicio a la hora de
hacer ese tipo de comentarios me llama
la atención la presencia de los hijos de
joe biden y particularmente porque si yo
mal no estoy y obviamente espero que los
televidentes ustedes me corrijan pero si
hay algo que me llama la atención es que
no se ha hecho mención del impi che y
que bien podría ser el gran talón de
aquiles para donación o no porque
obviamente procede donald trump a decir
que a pesar de este impeachment y de la
investigación de road de the brand de
mahler
pues se sigue manteniéndose en la
presidencia pero yo creo que lo que ha
hecho
yo bailé con la presencia de sus hijos
es que simplemente pues se quiere
mostrar como un padre de familia que
bueno ha enfrentado una dura situación
con la pérdida de su hijo pero
la presencia de hunter es lo que me
llama la atención porque si ustedes bien
recuerdan el hijo de joe biden estuvo en
el centro del huracán cuando se había
revelado que estaban
digamos pidiéndole al gobierno ucraniano
que proveyera información
de las de las de algún tipo de software
que podría indicar algún tipo de
perjuicio a la campaña de yo bailé y
querían apuntar precisamente al hecho de
que el hijo de joe biden estaba
trabajando para una compañía que se
llama buris mahuad viste ya saben todo
el entramado de este tema del
impeachment pero me llama la atención
que ese tema no se ha tocado no se si se
llegara a tocar más adelante seguro que
sí pero por lo menos en esta convención
lo que hemos visto es de proyectar a
iovine en como un padre de familia y que
ha sobrevivido pues y que ha perdurado
prácticamente ya he aguantado pues ese
difícil pérdida de un hijo y bueno y
otras pérdidas familiares que él ha
enfrentado pero creo que estaban ha sido
una pregunta respecto a una ventaja que
tiene yo bailé sobre sobre donald trump
yo creo que como figura del
establecimiento como es yo bailé tal vez
se podría proyectar como una persona que
está dispuesta a negociar con o por lo
menos en el entendimiento de cómo se
maneja la la política tradicionalmente
porque si hay algo que donald trump
carece es por lo menos en la
interpretación de la ley eso lo hemos
hablado en ediciones anteriores donde él
procura
pero en procura prueba sus límites hasta
que los hasta que las divisiones de
poder se lo permiten y puede digamos lo
que ha hecho es tomar diga en este
proyecto es bastante controversial es de
hecho un reporte de emi si no señaló que
stephen myler quien es su consejero y
había ha solicitado que se separaran las
familias en la frontera y ese es uno de
los temas que yo creo que yo vaivén va a
tener que lidiar con los hispanos porque
tiene que garantizar uno que las
familias sean reunidas y es posible
porque obviamente creo que va a ser de
cierta manera imposible reunir a todas
las familias que fueron separadas
durante esa administración pero también
responder porque viene de una
administración que fue infame en la
manera en que se reportaron hispanos a
sus países más de 2 millones de hispanos
fueron deportados durante la
administración de barack obama por eso
se le llamaba a él como el de portador
en jefe y obviamente yo bailé ni son
parte de esa administración y yo creo
que ese es una cuenta pendiente que va a
tener que o bailén de cómo llegar al
voto hispano
para tener un plan de trabajo para
brindarle un como se diría un sendero a
la ciudadanía para muchas personas que
aspiran a ser nuevos ciudadanos de ese
país y personas que puedan participar de
manera activa en el sufragio del en el
sufragio universal y yo creo que esa es
una de las cuentas pendientes que
también va a tener que hacer yo bailén a
lo largo de esta de esta carrera
presidencial pero por lo menos yo creo
que si hay algo que tiene una ventaja es
que yo bailé puede ser un poco más
conciliatorio y que puede como lo hemos
mencionado anteriormente es una persona
que puede hablar con ambos lados del
partido obviamente una cosa que no ha
ocurrido por lo menos aquí con la
administración de donald trump porque si
lo han dicho los reportes es que tanto
nancy pelosi como donald trump no se han
hablado por meses
así que yo creo que eso también va a ser
una de las grandes ventajas que de hecho
bailan o por lo menos lo que se presenta
hasta el momento robert gracias quiero
ir hasta la ciudad de milwaukee con
nuestra invitada maría fernanda y
preguntarle algo de lo que usted dijo en
su intervención
robert es que el presidente donald trump
ha sido un mandatario de escándalos pero
siempre ha salido bien librado porque
raúl creo que eso habla de este la
institucionalidad de este país
él ha querido probar los límites de esa
institucionalidad y de la separación de
poderes y siempre se le ha restringido
o sea si se le ha perseguido
pero si el presidente creo que a su
manera de gobernar estos últimos años ha
sido cuando surge una noticia de algo
que no le es favorable a él oa su
administración
hemos visto que tiende a crear una
crisis o a desviar la atención con
cualquier otro tema elevar eso
y bueno y por ejemplo hace unos meses
cuando salió los reportes del desempleo
en eeuu que había llegado a niveles
históricos
de inmediato el presidente desvió la
atención y lo que pasó es que no se
hablaba entonces de ese número de
desempleo ha sido el presente de chrome
desde que fue candidato desde que era
candidato ha sabido cómo manejar a la
prensa y a los medios ha sido yo creo
que vamos a hablar durante décadas y
años de la política en este país antes
de trump y después de chrome de una
manera diferente de la que se habla
digamos antes de obama o después de
obama o de cualquier otro presidente
porque justamente es el este aprobado
los límites
vemos yo creo que con la elección del
presidente de trump y esto es algo de lo
que hablaba
el invitado que está en miami
que una revolución cultural y el péndulo
yo creo que se fue hasta el otro extremo
y si fuera a ganar este yo bailén el
péndulo volvería a un poco al centro y
eso es lo que hemos visto también en la
historia política de otros países que
hay como pues que se mueva de un lado de
un extremo del péndulo al otro pero que
siempre de una manera u otra la mayoría
de los casos se vuelve a ese centro y
creo que el presidente del bronx
la verdad si fuera a ganar un segundo
término no sé hasta que me diga o hasta
qué punto o qué áreas trataría de
empujar y ver hasta dónde le permite
llegar el exento de la ley sin embargo
de nuevo hablando de la fuerte
institucionalidad de este país vemos que
hay consecuencias las noticias del día
de hoy que se arrestó activa no ni a
otros consejeros nos indican que al
final del día si hay leyes y orden en
este país es que las instituciones son
más fuertes que la figura del presidente
y eso es algo que hay que resaltar de la
democracia americana que no si bien el
presidente de trump con sus acciones y
con su empuje de las reglas ha logrado
erosionar hasta cierto punto y también
erosionado la confianza al público hay
un límite y esas instituciones
hasta el momento han probado ser tres
siguientes
gracias maria fernanda quiero ir
entonces ahora por un momento a la
ciudad de miami en el estado florida con
ronaldo otro de nuestros invitados y
preguntarle un poco acerca de lo que
decía maría fernanda en milwaukee y es
que si usted está de acuerdo con que el
presidente es a manejar a la prensa y el
presidente de donald trump
a lo mejor desvía estos temas
importantes cada vez que hay una crisis
en el país él lanza como esa especie de
bomba de humo si está de acuerdo con eso
no creo yo lo que creo es que chrome
simplemente está en todas partes
está en política exterior está en
política interior está con la economía
está con el coronavirus está ocupándose
de muchísimos temas simultáneas está con
venezuela está con irán está con él el
tratado de paz que acaba de hacer en con
los emiratos de israel que lo estaba
empujando está en todas partes está con
china está con taiwán está con rusia
está en la mente pero ya va a hablar yo
vayan y habla yo bailén y vuelvo con
usted adelante de conducta y de
respuesta movimientos derechos civiles
nos dio esa sabiduría tiene a la gente
la luz ellos encontrarán la vida
denle a la gente la luz estas son
palabras para nuestro tiempo el
presidente actual ha dejado eeuu en la
oscuridad por mucho tiempo
mucha rabia y mucho miedo mucha división
aquí y ahora les doy mi palabra si
ustedes me dan la confianza de la
presidencia buscaré lo mejor de nosotros
no lo peor sería un aliado de la luz no
de la oscuridad es tiempo para que
nosotros el pueblo nos unamos y no se
equivoquen unidos podemos y superaremos
esta temporada de oscuridad en estados
asociados escogeremos la esperanza los
hechos soy un demócrata orgulloso que
estaré orgulloso de llevar la bandera de
nuestro partido a la elección general
así que es un gran honor y con humildad
que acepto esta nominación para
presidente de los eeuu de américa
pero mientras seré un candidato
demócrata seré un presidente
estadounidense trabajaré duro por
aquellos que no me apoyaron tan duro por
ellos como lo hice o lo haré por
aquellos que sí votaron por mí ese es el
trabajo de un presidente representar a
todos nosotros no solamente a nuestra
base oa nuestro partido este no es un
momento partidista este debe ser un
momento estadounidense es un momento con
una causa por la esperanza por nuestro
futuro con luz para ver el futuro y con
amor unos por otros
eeuu no solamente una colección de
intereses que chocan o de estados azules
o rojos somos mucho más grandes que eso
somos mucho mejores que eso hace casi un
siglo
en un momento de gran incertidumbre de
desempleo y miedo golpeado por una
enfermedad por un virus dijo que iba a
recuperar y triunfar
pensaba que había que eeuu lo haría y lo
hizo y nosotros podemos hacerlo
igualmente esta campaña no se trata sólo
de ganar votos se trata de ganar los
corazones y si el alma de los eeuu
ganarla por los generosos no por los
egoístas por los trabajadores que
mantienen a este país andando no
solamente los privilegiados que están
arriba por aquellos en esas comunidades
que han conocido las injusticias de una
rodilla en el cuello por esas personas
que ven cómo se reducen las
oportunidades ellos merecen la
experiencia de la promesa estadounidense
merecen experimentar de manera total
ninguna generación sabe lo que se les va
a pedir todo lo que podemos saber es si
estamos listos cuando llega a ese
momento y ahora la historia nos ha
entregado uno de los momentos más
difíciles que eeuu haya enfrentado jamás
cuatro crisis históricas todos al mismo
tiempo
una tormenta perfecta la peor pandemia
en más de 100 años la peor crisis
económica desde la gran depresión el
llamado a una justicia racial desde los
60s y las realidades y las amenazas
crecientes del cambio climático entonces
la pregunta para nosotros es la
siguiente estamos listos yo creo que sí
tenemos que estarlo todas las elecciones
son importantes pero sabemos que esta es
mucho más importante
como muchos han dicho estamos en un
punto de inflexión estamos en un momento
de peligro pero también de una
posibilidad extraordinaria podemos tomar
el camino de volvernos
más divididos y llenos de rabia un
camino de sombras y división y sospecha
o encontrar un camino distinto y dos
juntos tomar esta opción de cambiar de
reformar de unir un camino de esperanza
y de luz este es una dirección que
cambiará una vida esto determinará cómo
se verá a eeuu durante mucho mucho
tiempo el carácter está ahí dices la
decencia es lo que tienen que escoger la
ciencia la democracia todo está en la
elección
quiénes somos como nación que defendemos
y lo más importante quienes queremos ser
todo eso es lo que está en la elección
la elección no podría ser más clara no
se necesita retórica
simplemente juzguen a este presidente
por los hechos 5 millones de
estadounidenses con 19 más de 170 mil
muertos de lejos mejor perfomance de
ninguna nación en la tierra
y más de 50 millones de personas que han
pedido subsidios de desempleo más de 10
millones de personas que van a perder su
seguro de salud este año
uno de cada seis negocios han cerrado
este año y este presidente difícil si es
reelecto saben lo que va a ocurrir los
casos y las muertes se mantendrán muy
altas más negocios tradicionales van a
cerrar y esta vez para siempre las
familias trabajadores van a luchar y
tener problemas para salir adelante y el
1% obtendrá miles de millones de dólares
en nuevos recortes fiscales y el ataque
a la forma volcker continuará hasta que
quede destruido quitándole el seguro de
salud a más de 20 millones de personas
incluyendo más de 15 millones que
dependen del medicaid y acabar con las
protecciones que el presidente obama
trabajo tan duro para aprobar y para
personas
y que tienen condiciones preexistentes y
hablando del presidente obama fue un
honor servir junto a él como su
vicepresidente de gm tomar este momento
para decir algo que casi no decimos
gracias señor presidente usted fue un
gran presidente un presidente que
nuestros hijos podían admirar nadie va a
decir eso de la persona que ocupa la
casa blanca lo que sabemos de este
presidente es que si te dan cuatro años
más será lo que ha sido por estos cuatro
años un presidente que no toma
responsabilidad que se rehúsa a liderar
qué culpa a otros que se acerca a los
dictadores y que aviva las llamas del
odio y la diversión se despertará cada
día creyendo que ese trabajo se trata de
él y nunca de ustedes si ese es el país
que quieren para ustedes para sus
familias para sus hijos
yo veo en eeuu distintos uno que es
generoso y fuerte
que es humilde uno que podemos
reconstruir juntos como presidente el
primer paso que tomaré será controlar el
virus que ha acabado con tantas vidas
porque hay que entender algo que el
presidente no ha entendido nunca vamos a
recuperar la economía nunca haremos que
nuestros niños regresen de manera segura
a las escuelas nunca tendremos nuestra
vida de vuelta hasta que nos enfrentemos
a este virus de la tragedia donde
estamos hoy es que no tenía que ser así
simplemente miren alrededor no es así en
canadá o en europa o en japón o
prácticamente ninguna otra parte del
mundo y el presidente sigue diciéndonos
que el virus va a desaparecer está
esperando un milagro bueno tengo
noticias para él es ningún milagro
llegará
liberamos el mundo en casos confirmados
en muertes nuestra economía está
destruida donde los asiáticos latinos y
los afroamericanos llevan lo peor de
esto y después de todo este tiempo el
presidente aún no tiene un plan pues yo
sí lo tengo si soy su presidente desde
el día 1 vamos a implementar una
estrategia nacional que yo he estado
presentando desde marzo vamos a
desarrollar y desplegar pruebas rápidas
con resultados inmediatos haremos que
los suministros médicos y los equipos de
protección que necesita el país
los construiremos aquí en el país para
que nunca más estemos a la merced de
china o algún otro país extranjero para
proteger a nuestra propia gente nunca
nos aseguraremos que las escuelas tengan
los recursos necesarios para abrir de
manera segura y efectiva pondremos la
política del lado
dejaremos que los expertos hablen para
que la gente pueda obtener la
información que merece y necesita una
verdad honesta y clara que ellos pueden
soportar tendremos un mandato nacional
para aportar máscaras no como un peso
sino como un deber patriótico para
protegernos unos a otros y asegurarnos
que haremos lo que debimos haber hecho
desde el principio nuestro presidente
actual ha fallado y ha fracasado en su
nación más básica con la nación ha
fracasado a la hora de protegernos a la
hora de proteger a eeuu y queridos
estadounidenses eso es algo imperdonable
como presidente les hago una promesa
protegeré a eeuu nos defenderemos de
cualquier ataque que podamos ver o no
siempre sin excepción cada vez
miren yo comprendo comprendo lo difícil
que es tener esperanza en este momento
en esta noche de verano déjeme tomar un
momento para hablar a ustedes que han
perdido a alguien y yo sé lo que eso se
siente perder a alguien que has amado y
sé y conozco el cebolla negro que
sientes en el pecho que parece que te
estuviera succionando y es algo doloroso
cruel e injusto como la vida puede ser a
veces
pero aprendido dos cosas lo primero es
tu ser amado puede haber seguido de la
tierra pero nunca se irá de tu corazón
siempre estarán contigo siempre los
escucharás y segundo he encontrado a
través de la pérdida del dolor que lo
mejor es encontrar un propósito
como hijos de dios todos tenemos un
propósito en la vida tenemos un gran
propósito como nación abrir las puertas
de la oportunidad para todos
para salvar nuestra democracia ser una
luz para el mundo nuevamente y
finalmente hacer respetar las palabras
del documento sagrado que fundó esta
nación que todos los hombres y mujeres
son creados iguales
dados por su creador con algunos
derechos inalienables entre ellos la
vida la libertad y la búsqueda de la
felicidad
mi padre era un hombre decente y se cayó
varias veces pero siempre se levantó
trabajo duro y construyó una maravillosa
vida de clase media para nuestra familia
me decía joey yo no espero que el
gobierno resuelvan mis problemas pero
claramente espero que los entiende y
después de un trabajo se trata de mucho
más que un cheque y se trata de tu
dignidad se trata de el respeto se trata
de tu lugar en la comunidad se trata de
ser capaz de decirle a tu hija ya tu
esposa las cosas van a estar bien y
decirlo de manera sincera nunca olvidaré
esas lecciones es por eso que mi plan
económico se trata de empleos de
dignidad de respeto y de comunidad y
juntos podemos y vamos a reconstruir
esta economía y cuando lo hagamos no
solamente vamos a construir sino a
reconstruir mejor con rutas modernas con
banda ancha puertas aeropuertos como una
nueva fundación de nuevo
para el crecimiento con agua limpia para
cada comunidad con 5 millones de empleos
para que el futuro sea hecho en eeuu con
el sistema de salud los deducibles más
bajos
construyendo sobre la forta volcara que
le está tratando de destruir con un
sistema de educación que entrene a la
gente para los mejores trabajos del
siglo 21 no hay nada de eso que los
trabajadores de este país no puedan
hacer y cuyo costo no evite que la gente
vaya a la universidad y que sean
aplastados por la deuda cuando salgan de
ahí con un sistema de cuidado infantil
que sea y que haga posible que los
padres vayan a trabajar y que los
mayores puedan quedarse en casa con
dignidad con un sistema migratorio que
empodere a nuestros nuestros valores y
que nos refleje y también a los
sindicatos porque son ellos los que
construyeron la clase media con pago
igualitario para las mujeres con
salarios en aumento con los cuales
puedes cuidar y criar a una familia y si
vamos a hacer más que trabajar por estas
personas finalmente les vamos a pagar
haremos y trabajaremos para superar el
cambio climático que no solamente es una
crisis sino que es una oportunidad
enorme una oportunidad para que
lideremos el mundo en energía limpia y
creemos millones de nuevos trabajos que
paguen bien en el proceso y podemos
pagar por estas inversiones acabando con
esas brechas y los recortes de impuestos
que el presidente ha dado al 1% y a las
grandes corporaciones algunas de las
cuales ni siquiera pagan impuestos para
nada porque no necesitamos un código
fiscal
[Música]
que premia la riqueza más de lo que
premia el trabajo no quiero castigar a
nadie
lejos de eso pero ya ha pasado mucho
tiempo de que las personas más ricas y
las grandes corporaciones de este país
paguen su parte justa
y para las personas de la tercera edad
la seguridad social es una obligación
sagrada una promesa sagrada hecha por la
cual pagaron el presidente actual quiere
romper esa promesa ha propuesto eliminar
un impuesto que paga por la mitad de la
seguridad social sin ninguna manera de
acabo de devolver ese ingreso faltante
yo no voy a permitir que eso ocurra si
soy su presidente vamos a proteger la
seguridad social y medicare ustedes
tienen mi palabra
una de las voces más poderosas que hemos
escuchado en el país y que escuchamos es
de la gente joven están hablando sobre
la injusticia y la inequidad que está
creciendo en el país la injusticia
racial económica medioambiental
yo escucho sus voces y sé que ustedes
pueden escucharlas también a esta
amenaza existencial que representa el
cambio climático
el miedo de recibir un disparo en una
escuela o cuando estás en tu primer
trabajo será el trabajo del próximo
presidente restaurar la promesa
estadounidense para todos y no tendré
que hacerlo solo porque tendré a una
gran vicepresidenta de mi lado
la senadora kamala harris es una voz
poderosa para esta nación su historia es
la historia estadounidense
ella conoce los obstáculos
que han enfrentado tantas personas las
mujeres las mujeres negras los asiáticos
los inmigrantes los que se han quedado
atrás
pero ella ha superado cada uno de esos
obstáculos que han enfrentado y nadie ha
sido más rudo con los grandes bancos y
el lobby armamentístico nadie ha sido
más rudo atacando a la administración
por su extremismo es su fracaso a la
hora de seguir la ley y decir la verdad
y yo venimos de familias y de ahí
tenemos nuestra fortaleza hay estado y
su familia para mi tío y la nuestra
he dicho muchas veces que ningún hombre
merece un gran amor y mucho menos dos
pero yo he conocido a dos después de
perder a mi esposa en ese accidente
llegó a chivas mi vida ella reconstruyó
nuestras familias es una educadora una
madre una madre militar y una fuerza
que no se puede parar si ella pone su
mente en algo simplemente quítate porque
ella lo hará lo cumplirá
será fue una gran segunda dama y sé que
será una gran primera dama para esta
nación porque ella ama tanto a este país
y siempre tendré la fortaleza que
solamente puede venir de la familia
hunter y ashley todas nuestras nietas
mis hermanos y hermanas me levantan me
dan coraje
aunque ya no estén con nosotros algunos
de ellos wow me inspira todos los días
voy sirvió en el uniforme de esta nación
un año en irak y fue condecorado como un
veterano de esa guerra
entonces me tomó muy personalmente y
tengo una profunda responsabilidad de
servir como comandante en jefe seré un
presidente que esté con nuestros aliados
y nuestros amigos y les dejaremos claro
a los adversarios que los días de
acercarse los dictadores se acabó
bajo el presidente de byd en eeuu no
dará la espalda a las recompensas
por los soldados estadounidenses ni
tampoco permitiremos interferencias en
el ejercicio democrático del voto
y siempre me levantaré por nuestros
valores de dignidad derechos humanos
trabajaré por un propósito común
para un mundo más próspero seguro y
pacífico la historia la historia
nos ha enviado una tarea urgente y
seremos nosotros la generación que
finalmente acabe con el racismo de
nuestro carácter nacional
yo creo que estamos enfrentándonos a eso
creo que estamos listos hace solamente
una semana ayer fue el tercer
aniversario de lo que ocurrió en carlos
el cierre en sus ojos recuerden lo que
vieron en televisión
recuerden ver a esos neonazis y esos
supremacistas blancos saliendo de los
campos con antorchas en las manos con
las venas y escupiendo el mismo tipo de
antisemitismo que se excluía que se
escuchaba en europa en los años 30
recuerden ese choque de lo que ocurrió
después entre aquellos que expandían el
odio y aquellos que tuvieron el coraje
de enfrentarse a él
recuerden lo que dijo el presidente
cuando se le preguntó dijo que había
visitó personas muy buenas de ambos
lados eso fue un llamado a la conciencia
para nosotros como país y para mí un
llamado a la acción en ese momento yo
sabía que tenía que lanzarme la
presidencia como me lo enseñó mi padre
el silencio es complicidad si nunca pude
quedarme callado por complicidad en ese
momento dije que estábamos en la lucha
por el alma de esta nación y lo estamos
en una de las conversaciones más
importantes que he tenido en esta
campaña
fue con alguien que era demasiado joven
para votar
me reuní con jana floyd de 6 años el día
antes de que enterrar a su padre georg
floyd una niña increíblemente valiente
nunca olvidaré cuando me agaché hacia
ella para hablarle me miró a los ojos y
me dijo sí dando
mi papá cambio al mundo mi papá cambió
al mundo
sus palabras me llegaron a lo más
profundo del corazón tal vez el
asesinato de george floyd fue un punto
de inflexión tal vez yo santo y su
inspiración
pero sin importar como haya ocurrido
estamos listos para acabar con el peso
del odio por fin de una vez por todas
y después el trabajo duro
de eliminar ese racismo sistémica
nos dicen que hemos pasado por los
momentos más oscuros donde hemos logrado
los mayores avances y ahí hemos
encontrado la luz y en este momento tan
oscuro creo que podemos hacer un gran
progreso nuevamente que podemos
finalmente encontrar la luz
saben muchas personas me han escuchado
decir que creo que se puede definir eeuu
en una sobre palabras posibilidades que
es lo que define a este país donde todo
es posible y digo todos absolutamente
todos deberían recibir una oportunidad
de vivir tan lejos como los lleven sus
habilidades y sus sueños nunca podemos
perder eso en tiempos que son tan
retadores como estos creo que solamente
hay una manera de avanzar como un
estados unidos es un país unido en la
búsqueda de una unión más perfecta
unidos en nuestros sueños de un mejor
futuro para nosotros y para nuestros
hijos unidos en nuestra determinación
para hacer que los próximos años sean
brillantes están listos yo creo que lo
estamos esta es una gran nación somos
personas buenas y decentes por el amor
de dios
estos son los eeuu de américa nunca ha
habido nada
que no hayamos podido cumplir cuando lo
hacemos juntos
james y un poeta irlandés una vez dijo
la historia dice no esperes de este lado
de la tumba pero después una vez en la
vida la ola de la justicia puede
levantarse y puede rimar esta es la
manera de hacer que la esperanza y la
justicia riman con pasión y con
propósito ustedes y yo juntos una sola
nación bajo dios unidos en nuestro amor
por el país y por unos con otros porque
el amor es más poderoso que el odio y
que el miedo y también la luz es más
poderosa que la oscuridad es nuestro
momento es nuestra misión que la
historia pueda decir que al final de
este capítulo de la oscuridad comenzó
aquí esta noche a medida que llegaban la
luz la esperanza uniéndose a la lucha
por el alma de la nación es un una
batalla que ganaremos y lo haremos
juntos les prometo les prometo
gracias y que dios los bendiga y
queridos proteja a nuestras tropas
el discurso de la noche del discurso del
candidato presidencial demócrata ya
oficializado el candidato aceptando su
nominación el discurso de joe biden dijo
que era el tiempo de unirse como
estadounidense es el tiempo de superar
la oscuridad dijo que ya llegó el
momento a partir del día de hoy llegó el
momento de cambiar la oscuridad por la
luz acepto por supuesto como ya lo
decíamos la nominación a presidente de
la nación dijo que será un presidente
para todos los estadounidenses que va a
representar a todo el pueblo es un
momento de esperanza para el futuro
habló también de la pandemia de la
justicia racial de la crisis económica
derivada de esta pandemia de coronavirus
dijo que será el presidente que sacar a
eeuu de la división de la polarización
de la crisis económica y también será el
presidente para controlar esta pandemia
de coronavirus un poco reprochando como
ha sido entonces el manejo que le ha
dado el presidente de turnar trump a la
pandemia de coronavirus de hablando del
presidente de nación dijo que el actual
mandatario no
el actual mandatario aviva el odio y la
división habló de un eeuu que para él
era el eeuu generoso y fuerte también
habló sobre la pandemia de coronavirus
diciendo visitando el presidente de
donald trump que el virus no se va a ir
con ningún milagro que el milagro no
llegara dijo que el presidente donald
trump no tiene un plan para poder sacar
a eeuu de esta crisis económica y de
empleos generada por la pandemia habló
de que su plan contra la pandemia nace
de pruebas rápidas con resultados
inmediatos que las escuelas van a abrir
de una manera segura y efectiva dijo que
el uso de las mascarillas va a ser un
uso patriótico para protegerse los unos
a los otros y no como un peso hablo
también nuevamente el presidente de
nación diciendo que fracasó a la hora de
proteger a eeuu y dijo que si el pse es
el nuevo presidente de la nación el
próximo 3 de noviembre cuando sean las
elecciones presidenciales dijo que su
tarea era proteger a eeuu
proteger y estar para los
estadounidenses cada vez que lo
necesiten hablo de las pérdidas de su
vida y habló también de encontrar un
propósito a la vida un propósito a la
nación habló de su plan económico
también de generar empleos de la
dignidad para los trabajadores del
respeto para los trabajadores del
sistema educativo también habló del
sistema migratorio que dijo que va a
empoderar los valores de la nación
trabajará también por supuesto para el
cambio climático que es otro fuerte
dentro de la campaña de joe biden habló
de una energía limpia también habló de
la seguridad social para las personas de
la tercera edad afirmó que va a proteger
la seguridad social y también el
medicare dijo que llegó el momento
también de rechazar la desigualdad
social dijo que los jóvenes en ese
momento estaban reivindicando sus
derechos en las calles habló por
supuesto también de su fórmula
vicepresidencial que aceptó su
nominación avión habló el día de ayer de
kamala harris
su historia la literal la historia de
eeuu una mujer que ha superado los
obstáculos que se le han presentado en
la vida y también habló de su
responsabilidad de responsabilidad de
dubai de de servir como comandante en
jefe y que no permitirá ningún tipo de
interferencia en el ejercicio del voto
hablo de lograr un mundo seguro y
pacífico eso básicamente entonces es lo
que habló el candidato joe biden por
supuesto también mencionando adwords
floyd diciendo que era un punto de
inflexión en su vida y dijo en ese
momento cuando habló de floyd que iba a
acabar con el peso del odio eliminar el
racismo sistemático en eeuu y una unidad
del pueblo estadounidense para un mejor
futuro
eso en resumen básicamente lo que dijo
el candidato joe biden vemos entonces en
pantalla la celebración de las personas
en los carros a las afueras de este
centro de convenciones donde baiden
ofreció su discurso y también está
entonces ahí ya
saludando a todos sus seguidores ahí
está
by denny por supuesto al lado kamala
harris acompañada de su esposo como lo
hace hace lo propio en el candidato joe
biden con su esposa entonces las
celebraciones ya oficialmente finalizado
este cuarto y último día de convención
demócrata en eeuu de cara entonces a
estas a estas elecciones del 3 de
noviembre y ya entonces esperemos que la
semana que viene la convención
republicana retomemos entonces para
analizar los puntos más importantes de
lo que fue el discurso de joe biden y
también analizar un poco y luego fue
esta convención demócrata y vuelvo con
el señor aledo en la ciudad de miami que
antes de que hablara baiden estábamos
con él como vio el discurso del
candidato yo bailé en muchos medios de
comunicación sobre todo la prensa
estadounidense dijo que este iba a ser
el disco
de su vida lo fue
bueno creo que ha sido el discurso más
importante que ha dado en su vida hasta
este momento estaba haciendo una
una llamada más o menos por decirlo así
apasionada suplicando el voto de una
manera
con compasión con desesperación por
favor voten por mí por favor ahora
salgan y voten por mí les voy a dar el
cielo de las maravillas y voy a hacer
todo y todo y voy a acabar con el
racismo y voy a acabar con todos voy a
darles un país maravilloso bla bla bla
bla creo que me parece que estaba
tratando de hacer eso y si este ha sido
el discurso más importante él ya había
tratado varias veces de ser presidente
había fallado y estaba tratando aquí de
dar un discurso aquí emotivo emocional
un discurso para tratar de llegar
a la mente a los corazones de los que
estaban escuchando ahora
desgraciadamente fallo en mencionar
muchas cosas objetivas y en muchos datos
los datos son los datos decía hábitat
está invita está bien decía la verdad
solamente está en las matemáticas fuera
de las matemáticas de no hay verdad y
está muy bien hablar con emoción y
compasión pero si te fallan las
matemáticas y los datos pues estás dando
un discurso vacío aunque yo eres y
aunque grites y aunque haga mucha
emoción
una de las cosas que falta es mejorar
muchas cosas dijo que no se acercará a
ningún dictador que no permitirá que se
acerque el presidente va a ir meter no
se acercará a ningún dictador pero fue
obama biden quien se acercó a la
dictadura comunista de cuba fue el jefe
fue fue su administración obama bailen
quienes se acercaron a los comunistas de
cuba vice le dijo que no se acercara a
ningún dictador pero fue obama en quien
se acercó e hicieron el trato con los
ayatolás de irán nada democráticos
completamente radicales musulmanes
chiítas fueron ellos fue el que se
acercó a esos dictadores comunistas en
cuba y a los radicales musulmanes en
irán dijo que su administración no iba a
hacer nada para recompensas que rusia da
por los soldados americanos en
afganistán yo estuve en afganistán tres
veces yo fui asesor de la policía afgana
en kabul y les puedo decir que los
talibanes no necesitan ninguna
recompensa rusa además el odian a la
oficina de inteligencia de eeuu
la el pentágono la defense intelligence
es decir los dos dijeron que ese reporte
que mencionó bailen ahí que ruso estaba
dando recompensa por salvar al soldado
americano en afganistán era ciento por
ciento falsa estaba aquí repitiendo en
una teoría conspirativa que ya odian hay
y el pentágono ya completamente di ponte
ya completamente dijeron que era
completamente falsa
estaba hablando de que había fallado
trump con el coronavirus porque hay
ciento de más de 160.000 muertos lo que
no mencionó es que el modelo inicial
eran dos puntos dos millones de muertos
y ahora parece que se va a mantener si
hay suerte con la ayuda de dios por
debajo de los 200 mil muertos durante
los próximos meses o sea que bajarlo de
dos puntos dos millones a menos de
doscientos mil no están tan
catastróficos están horribles como
bailén dice
es mencionó dijo que eeuu era el peor
país de coronavirus en el mundo pero
según las estadísticas oficiales bélgica
perú en españa el reino unido italia
suecia chile están mucho peor en muertes
que eeuu
hablo de la el racismo institucional
pero se le olvidó decir que según los
estudios oficiales en el 1900 en el 2018
7 mil 400 mujeres negros murieron por
homicidio pero solamente menos de 15
murieron desarmados a manos de la
policía menos del 1 del 0.1 por ciento
además un estudio de harvard en el 2015
leer no no lo mencionó para nada si dice
que no existe racismo en los shootings
de los policías que los policías blancos
son mucho más improbable a que maten a
los negros desarmados que otros policías
negros o policías hispanos son datos que
se le olvidó mencionar completamente a
valdés se le estaba tratando de unificar
gente del centro de la izquierda
mencionó a los jóvenes o sea estaba
tratando de conseguir a los jóvenes
idealistas de sandler que estaban
tratando de señora lenguas etc le pidió
que sea lo más breve posible ya para
terminar para darle paso a nuestros
otros invitados
para terminar el especial de noticias
nos dicen otra cosa que agregar
brevemente
así lo último que se le faltó decir bye
bye ten en su discurso era un discurso
muy muy amplio estaba tratando de ganar
la gente del centro tratando de quedar
bien con black light matter tratando de
quedar bien con los jóvenes
universitarios de sanders estaba
tratando de unificar al partido pero
obviamente fallo de datos fallo de
estadísticas estaba con las narrativas
infundadas que ya habían descartado el
pentágono yo dije nike no había no
mencionó para nada el trato con cuba que
hizo su administración al trato cuando
garantizó su administración y un dato
importante según las estadísticas
oficiales del gobierno eeuu no me lo
estoy inventando yo no me lo estoy
inventando yo no es nada que llegue la
imaginación
según en el 2007 aproximadamente una de
cada cinco familias latinas recibían
food stamps en eeuu y eso era
aproximadamente el 25 por ciento del
total y cuando las familias latinas sin
datos en realidad mentes nuevas al país
de nadie
gracias por su intervención voy
rápidamente entonces como maría fernanda
en milwaukee hablemos del otro punto muy
importante del discurso de biden contra
el racismo podrá valle entonces eliminar
el racismo sistemático en eeuu
raúl creo que las protestas y
movimientos los últimos meses en eeuu
pero también en el mundo le han dado una
especie de vida nueva a este tema de la
desigualdad y de la del racismo en eeuu
que es un tema que no se ha logrado
conciliar que es un tema que afecta de
manera muy real
a las comunidades esté afroamericanas
y su promesa de elegir a una
vicepresidenta afroamericana ya lo hemos
cumplido
yo creo que
que el hecho por ejemplo de que cámara
sea su vicepresidenta el hecho de que
haya tenido a mike bloomberg quien lo
atacó este que atacó a job airén durante
la campaña presidencial muestran que yo
va a ir en es un candidato que deja de
lado su ego y que está dispuesto a tomar
un tono reconciliatorio está dispuesto a
tener puentes está dispuesto a volver a
traer a eeuu a unir a eeuu y eso fue lo
que vimos en este mensaje del presidente
del candidato presidencial yo bailé es
no voy a poder hablar de todo pero yo
creo también fue un discurso sin
sorpresas fue un discurso que bueno esté
bastante sencillo en el sentido de que
no no se fue por los tecnocrático este
como hablaban nos invita el invitado
al principio del programa de que iba a
ser un discurso cargado de datos y
estadísticas y tecnocrático sino más
bien fue un discurso
joe a los americanos sencillo este donde
no se esté donde donde explicaba su
visión y su mensaje y yo creo que fue un
discurso si éste sin sorpresas donde
tendría algunos puentes y veremos cómo
seguirá así es la interrumpió para ello
entonces con robert valencia robert muy
brevemente tenemos aproximadamente un
minuto y medio dos minutos bueno minuto
y me dijo la verdad para sus presiones
sobre esta convención demócrata que ya
llegó a su final del discurso de kuwait
yo lo que puedo agregar ya no me gustaba
subieran ustedes dividido y tomase tipo
en este último segmento yo creo que la
compasión yo creo que para mí ese fue
uno de los puntos más sobresalientes el
invitado de miami dice que aquí
solamente estamos basados en números y
yo creo que aquí no se puede tratar a la
gente como si fueran robots
yo creo que decir que solamente fueron
170 mil muertos y que no fueron dos
punto menos dos millones no me parece
que es fantástico que no hemos llegado a
esa cifra pero de cualquier manera esto
no podemos pintarlo y de ponerle azúcar
como se dice
y ver las cosas desde una óptica de
color de rosa y yo creo que eso fue lo
que hizo precisamente iovine en apelar a
esa compasión que nunca tuvo donald
trump en el momento más difícil de la
pandemia porque él prefirió a politizar
una un virus que no conoce de políticas
y él y desafortunadamente si él hubiera
tomado una acción más inmediata si
hubieran disminuido de los muertos y
obviamente no podemos ver las cosas
solamente como si fueran números porque
estas son familias que han perdido
familiares valga la redundancia y donde
hay un dolor profundo y ese es el dolor
al cual yo bailén quiso apelar al
comienzo de su discurso bueno ya los
datos y cómo va a llegar a eliminar el
racismo como él dice bueno eso yo creo
que ya va haciendo un tema que va a
tener que desglosar y deshilvanar en el
momento que lleguemos a los debates con
el presidente de natra
gracias a robert entonces por su palabra
por su opinión personal y si le quiero
agradecer muy fuertemente a todos
nuestros invitados a maría fernanda en
milwaukee a ronaldo en miami y a robert
valencia en la ciudad de nueva york
lamentablemente que se me acabe el
tiempo por supuesto también a nuestras
corresponsales en mamá en sala en la
ciudad de nueva york y diana castañeda
desde washington de la capital
estadounidense también por supuesto a
ustedes nuestros televidentes que
siempre están acompañándonos y
prefiriendo nuestra señal france24 en
español por el momento yo me despido
hasta una próxima oportunidad hasta
luego